une production du studio sfr
vient venu au sans filtre présenté par
kiss me le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut nous inviter date seach ph
canton avec moi d'une plante caisse me
viennent toujours de lancer en
application en fait sur leur site web
qui vous permet de désarmer vous même
votre caisse de téléphone fait qu'en
fait non plus de 150 lits compte que
vous avez juste besoin de drag and drop
sur votre caisse vous pouvez mettre les
citations vous voulez pour créer
vraiment le qu'est-ce qui vous
représente aller voir leurs outils c'est
vraiment mail intégré vous n'avez pas
besoin d'être un expert en deux ans puis
quand vous avez acheté un étui oubliez
pas de fusion notre code sans fil
20% de rabais
puisque c'est ça qui suit cette semaine
on reçoit geneviève est vraie elle qui
mit sushis à la maison qui vous la
connaissez peut-être soit pour les
comptoirs de sushis soit pour son
service de sushis à la maison soit pour
ses livres une femme réellement
inspirante dans le temps dans tous les
sens du terme une personne qui a vécu
une enfance vraiment très difficile avec
des parents toxicomanes alcooliques les
violences à la maison clic russie malgré
ce qui s'est passé dit sylvain game 7
enfants disent il a créé vraiment un
projet qui est incroyable qui est qui
qui sont entreprises me sont chers la
maison qui est drôle et pétillante elle
von ah les histoires rocambolesques à
raconter c'était vraiment un grand d un
superbe au podcast avec génial et vraie
définition d'une personne forte quand on
exhibe encore l'ambiance juste avant
d'aller vous laisser la conversation on
va les remercier nos commanditaires
le pas de carte est présenté par nos
amis de vivre l'outil qui nous encourage
depuis le début c'est un tout premier
commanditaire sont toujours le on les
adore et on adore leurs produits on
adore leur soumission à l'ordre leurs
pleut moins disputer le mange
régulièrement le matin c'est bon c'est
sentir la différence avoir tous plus
délicieuses les unes que les autres ces
protéines et très james bond timothy
hier
pierre il ya plusieurs façon dont je
veux simplement j'ai normalement ans
mission qu'il mangeait un top 5 on peut
les manger en crème glacée hambol souci
ph c'était des bars et les pubs secondes
alors voici comment fait-il pour matin
gagne je me fais des ports c'est que vu
ça c'est le dr claus guth it octo
un peu l'air d'avoir
juste d'un mile la préparation
[Musique]
mot arabe c'est quand ça m'a pris
littéralement une minute trente
l'épaisseur au congélo qui sort
chez que ça commença par rapport en
conséquence bon pour la santé pour les
jours chauds qui restent à l'été
merci
donc comme vous peut voir pour les
journées de canicule comme les journées
qu'on vit en ce moment à issy fait
vraiment chaud les choses si je me
prendrais un petit ou un petit pop ce
que vivent on a un code promo pour vous
autres qui le sans filtre 15 pour 15 $
of +2 ce mythique avec une belle offre
exclusive on s'en fait pas de casque
pour vous assurez vous d'utiliser puis
assurez-vous aussi de cliquer sur le
lien qu'on va mettre dans la descente du
port catalan après j'ai essayé de lire
le lien puis ça va moyen bien lire en
lien des plis fait comment le mettre
dans la description et assurez vous de
passer par ce lien là comme s'ils vont
savoir que c'est nous qui vous envoie
pis ils vont être mieux capable de
calculer
les impacts de cette publicité vous
savez comment ça roule merci avis merci
à vous autres qui n'ont pas tout oui le
podcast de cette semaine et présenté par
nos amis chez police lit qui reviennent
vous savez moi le sommet c'est quelque
chose qui m'importe beaucoup parce que
faut que tu dormes comme du monde si tu
veut maximiser la performance oui
physique mais aussi cognitives puis vous
savez ici au civil par quatre
performances cognitives c'est
de lancer leur nouvelle oreiller
orthopédique c'est la première oreiller
le premier un oreiller le premier
oreiller du genre fait entièrement au
canada avec une mousse anti microbiennes
et aussi une nouvelle technologie de
régulation de la chaleur peut prendre un
peu de bien faire le meilleur de
plusieurs bienfaits de le rayer
orthopédique premièrement ça va te
donner une légère élévation de la tête
qui peut prévenir des problèmes comme
l'apnée du sommeil les brûlures
d'estomac il ya aussi les motos donc
elle panoplie de désagréments qu on
préfère éviter éviter et en plus on peut
le personnaliser le guide et à chablis
personnalisable ta queue
plus tard il la technologie de
personnalisation des oreillettes pour
description de l'abandon le rester nous
mêmes le pire c'est vraiment des bons
oreiller on a un code promo pour vous
qui le sf 15 15% rabais sur vos
commandes police lit assurez vous de
cliquer sur le lien qui va être dans la
destruction du podcast à vous emmener
directement vers la bonne page puis ça
va aussi leur montrer qu'on vous envoie
avec mercy parler sleepy bonus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ja c'est parti merci d'être là
comment ça va ça va super bien à ndop
forme qu'au fond ah ouais jamais été
aussi en forme jamais de nom qu'est ce
qui fait que tu as tout à fond la gsxr
mois d'août avait sept je suis tout va
bien dans ma vie est merveilleux je sais
pas comment l'expliquer le sag au
spotlight sur un bon spot moi mais j'ai
toujours eu l'impression que j'étais sur
mon x parce qu'ils étaient j'ai créé un
peu ma vie finalement non en tout cas
c'est sympa en forme mais mes petits
comme je sais pas je trouve qu'il est
ici je vais avoir 35 ans dans un mois
pitié souvent quand c'est notre
obligation on fait une espèce de
rétrospective de où on est et puis on
est comment as tu le joues l'est puis je
commence à y penser parce que j'ai pas
haute ville mais je pensais à ma vie en
général c'est comme ça c'est cool quand
même ses sushis à la maison est c'est
juste un petit garçon en pleine santé
sur six c'est niaiseux mais je pense
qu'en 2021 de mettre l'accent sur le
fait qu'on ait tout en santé c'est
important
c'est son petit nom personnellement je
me sens épanoui il me sens bien et je
sais pas comme je contente de vivre
non mais c'est le phone 8 au dessus et
au dessus c'est la dernière année la
dernière année et demie pour pas mal
tout le monde ne dépasse plus rough and
dessus ou georges c'est comme tout a
continué d affaires a avancé puis metz
et sauf qu'ils étaient oui ça a été
rohff parce que type parce que comme
tout le monde personne ne s'attendait à
ce
métier j'ai quand même assez self made
woman fille débrouillarde en vie en
général actu m'apitoyer sur mon sort
pendant quatre minutes maximum d'avis
puis c'est ce qui est arrivé quand on
nous a annoncé qu'on ce qui m'a le plus
bouleversé à travers mes branches passé
souche à la maison c'est plein de vol et
l'autre les livres le service à la
maison les restaurants les comptoirs ce
qui m'a le plus affecté ces stec monde
intouchable étaient touchées et a dormi
mist à la maison je m'appelle ministre
mais mes chefs sushi qui vont chez des
gens partout québec ce ça me fera
marcher équipages comme un jour tu
m'aurais dit non à n'en ont pas pu aller
chez propres films aux genres et
faiblesses et surtout bien c'est comme
si pour moi c'est super drôle de film en
commun si la formule c'est fx si j'ai
pas de l'oie de loyer à payer embauché
n'y a pas de pertes on achète l'épicerie
avant d'aller chez vos cuisines tout on
connaît nos portions fin c'était comme
aux vrais sujets a raison c'est une
formule magique dans tous les sens
autant pour l'expérience que pour ma
chère qui le concept en général fa kart
on nous a dit n'avait pu aller chez les
gens moi je me retrouvais avec 40 filles
qui restaient dans leur vie chez eux il
y avait plus de travail bâclé je me
sentis comme quasiment marre d'avoir
inventé sur la vraie celle des filles d
comme relax tire quand jacques son prix
chez orbit école à la jet set j'ai
tellement essayé pendant des mois de
trouver des manières qu'on fasse dtk
hôpitaux nicole au saguenay mais oui
mais l'allemagne et ce après pas
cuisiner chez eux de venir me porter ce
chez nous oui mais c'est pas que ça
s'apprend des permis ça prend c'est
compliqué faut rentabiliser les gens
vont du bouquet il faut que ma miss ça
valait la peine qu aller à l'épicerie
fatick les gens sont plus serrés au site
exactement des portes monde sait qu'ils
ont acheté du calage
récompense le haut à la aux gens qui
dévalisaient les costaudes papier
toilette c'est une scène que cette
arrivée dans la ville
début des films de zombies mais c'est ça
faire des provisions parce que c'est
l'apocalypse mais pourquoi la toile et
c'est ça qui efface la comptal mais cet
axe et ça m'a bouleversé pilier
restaurant savait pas si on allait
pouvoir et à au moment où on ne fermait
les comptoirs me tentait pas dit que
c'était services essentiels le terme
existait pas vraiment encore fait que tu
sautes a pris à peu près le quelques
jours pour que je fasse comme oh qu'est
ce que je fais purge a inventé le
concept des boîtes mystères dans le fond
pour écouler les éventaires si c'était
vraiment ce point smart de ma part parce
que j'avais fait une bouffe moi je
voudrais acheter des jeux partie des
commandes kg on ne fermait on n'avait
pas une manger fac dans mes deux restent
au québec montréal j'inventais des
boîtes mystères avec ce que j'avais en
place comme bourdieu rien perdre les
gens savaient pas ce qu'ils bouquet au
début il a acheté une boîte mystère
souche à la maison savais que ça va être
des sushis mais sous quelle forme
ça a fonctionné en fout en fait ça me ça
me fait survivre à la première vague qui
apprend on aurait ouvert les auto-écoles
mai mais sinon j'ai fait j'ai aimé ce
parce que ça me prouver que je parce que
je suis comme eux pour preuve le pousse
à aller bien été le premier oui en
quelque sorte m'étais bien vendre tout
le temps risque aussi j'ai bon mettez ça
reste mes petites affaires à l'éveil de
sa com au mais ça m'a prouvé que j'étais
comme encore et toujours capable de me
débrouiller puis de faire comme on va
faire ce autres mappy ouais les faits
les services de souche à la maison c'est
ce que cet article tout le truc c'est la
première chose que toi laquelle de
commerce du bois en 2006 j'ai appris à
faire des sushis dans un petit
restaurant de québec jean charest coin
du pont et à l'arrière de simplex fou
déjanté qui implique
encore le lui ait l'air et au non non et
non pas qu
[Musique]
il ya longtemps qui est sis au fait que
dans le fond et ça comment j'ai appris à
faire des sushis l'homme était vraiment
belle et que c'est moi je viens d'un
milieu se parent pauvre fac quand j'ai
eu la job pour faire des sushis ce qui
est super contente parce que moi je me
suis pas dit oh mon dieu les sushis je
me suis juste dit si j'ai à prendre
enfin je vais pouvoir en manger tes
genoux étaient bien gourmande et fait
que quand j'ai appris à faire des sushis
mais je me souviens a inventé je n'avais
jamais vu autant de boeufs devant moi
toute ma vie puis je me suis rendu
compte que je goûtais dans ma tête je
savais pas su avant parce que le
magicien canton avant de 100% quant à
l'ailé note ou la prochaine arrivée ou
bien un artiste qui aime toi tu t'es
comme comment tu fais pour dit mettons
ce moment gaydamak oriente plus gaudin
qui n'aime pas sa tâche touche pas fan
de paria
oui c'est exact qui avait comme si
j'avais sur une table basse au bruit
avec un compartiment qui était on avait
des recettes préétabli mais je sais quoi
mais ça se peut pas que je suive société
comme vraiment classique péter kamikaze
ce système est correct mais mon arme
attaquer comme au monde ou miss ci
subissent au delà des fois mon boss par
tête s'il pleut l'inventaire des
nouveautés plus les clients y venait peu
chargé genres divers quelque chose
bougeait
inventé ça que je me suis mis à
explorer ce finalement ç'a vraiment
c'est pas prémédité jamais j'ai fait moi
dans la vie mais comme découverte dans
leur part pu rassembler en fait
maintenant et ma passion bien fonctionné
en face bagram puis à ce moment là je me
suis dit que je voulais que ma vie ça
soit long maquis sans fin je n'avais
rien prévu mais je me suis dit il faut
que je fasse c'est ce que j'aime oui
précisément noté à la limite tant pâté
chinois jeu le good dans ma tête mais je
lai jeu c'est vraiment des sushis je
tiens c'est vraiment l' amalgame de la
feuille de nori le riz les ingrédients
frais les fruits les sucrés salés les
poissons frej j'ai passé comme ceux que
j'ai participé est ce que est ce que
parce que on parle on en fait plus tard
le méthanol en a déjà parlé beaucoup
mais est-ce qu'ils mettront le toit en
grandissant j'imagine qu'ils des sushis
ce n'est pas quelque chose que tu manges
et souvent le nom c'est ça il avait
mangé une fois même âge et une fois
avant de savoir avant de commencer à
travailler ce resto le plus à redire
puis le 2 commencé à goûter de farah qui
longe après l'avoir avec soi exact vous
avez été invité en détiendrait aux
métropolitains deux semaines
impressionnant qui après c'est chez kobo
si je pensais jamais pouvoir me re payer
ça dans ma vie dit parce que j'ai jamais
vu loin c'est moi j'ai toujours un peu
dans le moment présent à court terme
parce que je patauge depuis j'essaye
juste de demain sortir surtout à cette
époque leur faim quand on me donnait
l'opportunité d'apprendre à faire des
sushis jeter comme naïveté oui j'étais
juste curieuse apprendre à faire ça
parce que tu es il sait quand on remonte
en 2006 c'était beaucoup d'amis dans ton
entourage qui sait rouler des sushis
favori dans un mc steak ou n'en veut pas
c'est comme jeter kulti par les amis tu
es comment as tu es chez nous à fait
humaine plus je m'installais bessat a
comme particularité on dirait que des
souliers on dit que les sushis pour moi
le petit c'est juste parce que j'en ai
jeté arrivé à un âge où est ce que le
monde mangeait seul mais on dirait que
dans ma tête c'est arrivé alors no one
shot qui avait le style et sushil la
nouvelle affaire la team et en début
2000 j'ai l'impression que ce qu'elle
n'avait pas de reste aussi le tien sushi
taxi db use ou y avait pas seule la
taille ou juste et un resto des bulles
exact
travailler c'est comme on dirait que
c'est arrivé début de ménage or voici
une nouvelle tendance qui nous vient du
japon puis
les gens étaient comme ça reste un peu
ça restera pas chaque lot de surprises
et kalma m'étais je sais pas moi j'ai
cru en cette arme était même paul
c'était juste comme un visa va rester
simplement je me suis la première fois
que mes parents avec des sushis à maison
plateau de sushis c'est un art en place
chez vous c'est une femme et deux camps
même de fruits de mer plus de poissons
ouais ouais mais après il faut que les
sushis plus empreint puis le jamais dans
ma bouche je l'aï recraché
ça roulait dans bouge c'est la ligue des
cadets quant à jamais goûté selon la
peine de mort il
m'a g j en fais il gèle ayant porté son
sa maison de personnes en jalles et pas
pire à l'enlever l'algue déroulait salle
débat les gens comme assistait comme à
une pellicule plastique au tome était
comme dino rythme tellement jaxa
fourchette mais c'est bien correct mais
si c'est un goût wells a pris bois qui
s'apprivoise
chose
ouais tu disais tu disais que tu étais
dans le moment présent puis je veux
qu'on parle de ça parce que parce que tu
es cas qu'on entend l'histoire de ton
enfance avec ta mère qui était qui
compte qu'ils avaient des problèmes de
consommation toxicomanie ton père qui
était aussi plein de consommation parce
qu'on en pense vraiment horreur dans
limoilou le tipi comme on s'imagine
limoilou mettront le pied pour ceux qui
viennent de québec à l'époque à l'époque
surtout un outil
tu dis quasiment trait commun comment
parce que tu racontes sera le peut-être
des dieux ya jamais mettons là on dirait
on ressent jamais la détresse quand je
t'entends par les deux teams sont le
titiller jamais l'espèce de
2,7 au pistou le temps genre ben non
mais moi j'étais allé de l'avant at il
dit est ce que tu penses que d'être dans
le moment présent ça te permet justement
de d'éviter de tomber dans dans l'
espèce de spirale descendante dax toi ma
fille de mais je pense que ça c'est
comme si il y en a qui me disait mon
délit j'ai fait une conférence pour la
croix-rouge en rien comme 300 personnes
qui le monsieur de la croix rouge a
redit personnes responsables d'ihh te
réussit à mettre un moteur de ferrari
dans une d'autres commentaires puis ça
va vraiment gros de toucher un peu comme
j'aime beaucoup mais aussi parce que
j'étais claquée et les huit mois comme
ça c'est vraiment juste comme ma
mécanique qui est vraiment différente
des popotes des autres métissé comme moi
personnellement 6h pas d'anges pas comme
sujet j'aimerais donner expliqué comment
je fais pour pas m'apitoyer ou comment
j'ai fait pour faire pas avoir
d'amertume ou da rancune envers la mère
qui qui se dopaient qui se prostituaient
puis tout seul puis je répondrais que je
t'ai toujours un peu dans l'espèce
d'esprit de faire comme non mais moi ce
que je veux dans ma vie c'est mémé
savoir ma vie parfaite nécessairement a
lancé je t'ai pas comme si loin mais
juste c'est dans le moment assez présent
pour me dire je pense pas que c'est
normal sauté et je me rappelle un moment
donné j'avais connu chez maman parce
qu'elle avait pas de téléphone qui m
mais c'est le genre évidemment le métier
maintenant je voulais des nouvelles
d'elle fallait que je colle dans son
trac house m'a paru un
peu près genre ça y est c'est un 18
heures au pub non non non vraiment peu
depuis plusieurs années puis moi je
m'ennuie d'herbe parce que tu es il
faudrait une mère en justice jalempo est
pas méchante est juste vraiment magané
outils de la vie en général jim murple
cogne dans son espèce de troubles qui
était sur le divan tes pieds étaient en
bout l'intention arty qui a été en
manque de double mais solide mais si
fascinant parce que ça lui prenait 20
dollars pour qu'elle arrête d'être dans
cette éthologue pic à petit pour vrai il
aurait pu mourir parce que ma mère a
consommé tellement que c'était même plus
un désir nécessairement d'être posée
c'est que ton corps il est comme you
j'en ai besoin comme je vois c'est is
pas pour rien qu'il ya des traitements
qui se font pour des gens qui ont eu des
douleurs mais ton chronique puis on
prend un médicament exploit faut qu'ils
oeuvrent avec un produit comme temps la
méthadone ou des choses comme ça mais ma
mère c'était vraiment ça dob de tous les
jours fac si elle n'avait pas et
personne faisait bien on va vous donner
un petit traitement de méthadone madame
s'est massé des prescriptions je me
rappelle avoir été obligé d'aller en
acheter
seyman phoque pour une jeune fille de
cet enfer jitsu et des mamans à se
droguer
et empêcher de moura sauver sa ville
exactement fakty moi dans ma vie j'ai eu
plein une situation comme ça où il a
fallu face des genres de drôle de choix
vraiment comme impliquant engagea facto
dans ma vie c'est comme si j'allais est
une personne qui allait prendre des
décisions qui allaient faire de son
mieux en tout cas dans tout les sens des
décisions que d'autres qui doivent être
prises puis que j'allais juste comme
vivre les moments ces gens sur le coup
je fais quoi puis comment j'ai agi comme
âge le tact pour ce qu'encore
aujourd'hui même avec toute la business
que j'ai je sais plus combien de gens
qui travaillent pour 15 matchs et à la
maison avec tout les départements
confondus c'est qu'ils ont ils vivent au
jour le jour c'est autant que j'ai des
projets j'ai des idées j'en vois dans
l'univers de mort mais il revient sur
papier
je pense qu'elle est pas quand j'étais
plus jeune j'étais un peu comme se jeter
comme au quai dans le moment le jeu dire
comment avec la situation puis j'ai dit
c'est bien mais tu es si j'avais su même
temps que ma marraine une fois qu'ils
peaufinent mathon leur importe quoi le
métier mettons que m'avait faite sentir
que j'avais été un one night et genre
une erreur ou si je serais probablement
police il sait c'est que ma mère à
travers toute sa maladie de dépendance
c'est devenu sur six mois ma ram est
mieux loti et marées fait mal tellement
calmes et miel comme et bebeto la
fois en fac je sais c'est ce qui m'a
sauvée itso il y avait tout et il y
avait dessus des moments de des moments
où est-ce qu'ils étaient post l'effet de
drogue puis de lucidité ou est-ce que tu
voyais était vraiment cette émotion là
derrière derrière la consommation non
non il avait jamais de moment aussi je
pense que je me dis aux souvenirs de ma
mère complètement sobre mais parce que
selon et elle emmène des milliards en
taxes potable
est en sevrage va y avait jamais été
vraiment de longs moments où était
elle-même j'en ai quelques dents parce
que tu es il ya plusieurs fois ou à
laisser derrière thérapie il ya
plusieurs fois ou sais je sais pas moi
ou elle avait pas de souci à ne pas
toujours consommé des drogues vraiment
hâte rachat le déjà été comme des trucs
de base tout seul le midi comme la bière
puis le pop culture mais même es salaam
a gagné mais elle était quand même
palpable l'homme leçon n était pas aussi
demandant que la drogue qui se faisait à
être revenus à la fin mai mais oui j'ai
sûrement senti dans la lucidité des
tessons espèces dames sont à maupiti
sont mamans elles auraient tout fait
pour moi à travers ce qu'elle avait
paulo tu es ma mère combien de fois
probablement quand elle avait pas à
manger puis que moi je dînais
puisqu'elle a mangé pas mais je me
rendais pas compte et les enfants c'est
un gros tu arrives les colts 7,80 veut
dignité comme maman j'ai faim j'ai
failli plier dimanche la même affaire
toute la semaine était juste comme force
après ton parent parce que tu es comme
mais elle est juste comme si tout ce
qu'on nomme est un peu pas à me le dit
mais à peut pas en même temps puisque je
comprends mais je comprends pas parce
que oui je suis jeune elle vit dans un
monde d'adultes mais je reste en phase
avec moi il ya bien des fois où tu es j
charles et pas jeter comment on mange
encore la même affaire plainte et comme
mais oui mais rien d'autre et la botte
de sous-sols d'église puisses tu es seul
tu es les banques alimentaires qui était
ma nuit à la diversité en banque
alimentaire ça n'existe pas de presse
kyodo fait que mais c'est elle qui m'a
donné le don de goûter dans ma tête ah
oui c'est ce que j'entendais dire que
fac avec la bouffe qu'à trouver bahia
réussissent à faire quand même des
bonnes choses puis c'est sa devise privé
puis à faisait ce cas pouvait aimer
métier aussi nos parents ils ont leur
visite et ils ont leur parcours ils ont
leur thé maman jessica vécu plein de
choses vraiment trash vraiment jeune
mais je saurai jamais parce que des cd
pis j'ai pas le temps comme l'avait
avancé ce sujet le thé exactement puis
mais tu es ya des gens qui voulaient pas
voir dans sa chambre sur son lit de mort
qui avec raison parce qu'elle a vécu des
choses capoter puis celle sa décision
est dans sa vie ça a été de s'engourdir
t c'est incroyable de briser cette roue
le lundi c'est le whale parce que
souvent tus générationnel et des
problèmes comme ceux puis c'est qu'ici
tu n'es dans un milieu vraiment
défavorisés et puis le suivi des
traumatismes qui font que tu répètes
cette espèce de pâte à la mêlée
d'arrivée puis de réussir à briser ce 6
mai c'est comme si encore une fois cet
après-midi ttg j'avais un petit voient
en moi qui ne disait pas ça la vie tg
je me disais sûrement autre chose cpie
pas que je voulais et et je voulais pas
j'avais pas vu précis
façon ça me rend ça rend pas heureux le
large en tête mais c'est je me suis dit
moi j'aimerais juste ce n'est pas pas
compter à la fin du mois et ses pigistes
des affaires normale normale en ce qu'on
se souhaite du moins de ne pas arriver
puis d'être à ses affaires chez
exane c'est vraiment littéralement sur
le balcon je suis saisi soit histoire
post intense le fait que oui d'avoir
brisé hier que je sais pas comment j
réussite et j'ai réussi juste de par le
désir de pau répéter les mêmes erreurs
mais c'était pas déçu parce que je me
disais je me dis pas je ne vais pas
répéter les mêmes erreurs je me disais
je veux posture n'était même pas autant
pour dénigrer leur parcours à mes
parents ou peu importe si tu es vraiment
juste moi l'abandonner quelqu'un qui me
dit pas ça m'avait vraiment pensé par un
aurait pu sortir par l'autre mais
finalement j'ai enregistré à ce moment
là se passe quand anton france domaine
était comme un outil facile à dire mais
finalement sam sam a marqué c'était
juste itavi c'est toi qui décideraient
noter que oui c'est beau mais ça me fait
mal même mais finalement c'est si vrai
parce que chaque fois je faisais de quoi
on dirait que ça me ramener à baisser
mois le thé c'est moi qui déciderai qui
décide c'est moi qui fais mon chemin et
en tout cas finalement pis avec les
cartes que tout dans les mains c'est au
cuistot qui joue avec jacques ferrier
matière c'est ce qui était chouette
aussi s'éjecter le guide de la famille
parfaite récemment à steinbourg au
cinéma puis c'est quand tu es tout
mettons le comme aux garçons mathon est
vraiment pas mal pris j'essaie de pas
exagérer ce que j'ai manqué quand
j'étais jeune ça serait mal à sézanne
mais dès que je me dis c'est lui il va
vivre il faut pas connaître ce que moi
j'ai vécu je vais essayer d'expliquer je
me suis dit mais en même temps ça va
être une autre vie complètement cefac
après ça c'est juste comme un peu de toi
de fondamentalement quitté parce que moi
je crois beaucoup à celle que on n'est
pas tous égaux le t on à quelque chose
une forme différente chacun t on autour
des tempéraments pour moi qui ai inventé
sur le lit les tempéraments de belgique
mais c'est exactement la même situation
et mon rêve commun ben oui exactement tu
sais c'est un peu moi pour moi c'est pas
une question on est tous différents mais
moi je pense qu'à travers mon parcours
j'ai pris le meilleur de mes parents
vraiment parce que je sais dit farah
différente et je le vois le team am ans
et quelle qualité mon père telle affaire
c'est qu'on alors que le terme et en a
mais ma mère c'est quelqu'un de super
drouot le team oman pouvait partir un
monologue de théâtre à 22 secondes qui
fait rire tout le monde autour de la
table petit mois souvent quand je me
laisse aller semer internet et j'aime
trop belle aux
comités cgeci que sa maman puis son côté
créatif aussi la bouffe mon père battait
superficiellement à d'autres chemins que
moi ça m'intéresse les autos qui on
partage cette passion l'appui j'essaie
de transmettre à mon garçon mais dont
parle pas de prix le genre on parle des
mécaniques des bons et tout ça puis son
côté débrouillardise aussi timon parce
quelqu'un de très résilient parce qu'ils
arrêtent de consommer puis il ya ces y
est de faire le plus possible la paix
avec son passé comme si je disais si on
a toutes nos vécus t qu'après ça c'est
de faire je vois tout de l'avant où je
rumine leur pierre cimon qui stagne
petit on en a tous déjà qu'on connaît
son comme un tueur est dans tout et déjà
les lions comme toujours le petit nuage
gris autour d'eux comme le goût de les
aider à pousser le nuage
peut pas aider quelqu'un qui veut
posséder aussi gelé compris avec ma mère
en train facture plutôt d'avoir eu ce ce
contre exemple de tes parents tu
consommer ce que ça a toujours été un
non catégorique de ou ou à manier une
croix de richmond hippique où tu aurais
pu aller dans ce chemin lmt décidé de
parler mais j'aurais pu parce que tu es
chez nous c'est comme normal titre
consommer ses factures ta limite je me
rappelle une fois une décote de
filaments à petit ses droits parce
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai l'âge que ma mère
avait quand même temps j'avais traité
matin que je sais pas moi je vais 35,6
jeu capable de faire mais ils avaient
mon âge quand ces sitcoms de fives n'ai
plus été commun que geneviève et s'est
hissé à la grosse daube de mesures on se
calme et on attend marama eu avec deux
factions matin j'ai toujours été plus
mature tout seul je m'occupais beaucoup
de mamans infectés comme très adulte
mettez ça faisait elle portait défaut
chez nous c'est quand même pas le sais
j'avais misé habiter chez notre maire
et georges arriva travail était axé ma
mère si fondamentalement quelqu'un de
partie que j'aurais pu leur échapper il
vraiment mais ça m'a vraiment toujours
cette peur j'ai commencé à boire de
l'alcool provimi j'avais jamais bu une
goutte d'alcool jamais le but est comme
l'énergumène déjà rythme thème path as
tu l'impression que parce qu'ils disent
héréditaire souvent les premiers
consommateurs de tout l'impression que
comme cate a pris ta première rangée
devant être faite aux défauts projet est
contenté d'utiliser cette plateforme
pour forme aux communautés d'alcool
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui me
voient des fois qu'elle coûte devant et
qui n'attend sur un mois est à g sont
comme j'ai vu doter conférence phare
2012 de trizay qu'ils aient pas comme la
vie change
vous
pouvez les voir
[Rires]
mes sept enfants cityzi beaucoup étaient
très fiers quand même de ne jamais avoir
consommé quoi que ce soit mais c'est
parce que j'avais aussi peur c'est puis
un moment donné bref dans ma vie j'ai
décidé de faire quelques choix qui m'ont
permis de me rendre compte que j'étais
capable d'avoir un certain contrôle sur
mon corte que ce soit le poids peut
importe le plus aux gens par paul adam
et je suis un mois deux mois à
kingston et blake
19 30 ans que chez comme capable sur
site dealé avec comme commence je
voulais un peu me traiter ainsi pour ces
travaux bieleu l'alcool betty la part
des mythes sur l'or et les petits jobs
pitié comme la grosse mode le genre de
tout ce qui est comme jean tardieu
faudrait bien que j'ai c'est sûr mais
j'ai pas commencé sur gros gin c'est sûr
que j'aurais fait le mécano terre mais
bref je me suis dit que j'avais envie un
peu d'annuler cette bâche noire là pour
moi parce qu'ouvrir une époque où je
mangeais même page en rebond qu'avait
quid en bière j'avais peur littéralement
de ressentir l'effet de l'alcool mais
j'avais toujours vu les côtés comme à
montréal
en train de faire la fête avec mes amis
des chèques au contraire dans ma tête
c'était inévitable bonne coupe devant un
réal qui s'est sentie capable tilman
remédier à une coupe de vin en mangeant
c'était ton travail puisqu'elle chef que
bois poppy tiges était vraiment
vraiment une bibitte si on veut un pis
je me suis dit si je suis capable et et
maîtrisez pas taille de mon alimentation
certaines petites choses dans ma vie
pour moi pour que je serais pas capable
de boire une coupe de vin salle déchiré
la face ça que j'ai commencé
tranquillement
chez nous fait une connerie parce
l'avouerez d'école la première chose vue
la première journée la première premiers
moments acte amis de l'alcool baisse et
du vin blanc ok c'est pas
la bière le look good the time of fame
temps je me sentais pas papa peloter des
fois même ne faisait genre est cependant
le couple jeter comme si je voulais tu
gagnes pourcentage voulait avec les
coupes de pâques
il y aura juste boire un coup et j'en
faisais pas partie ça pas bien je vois
tu vas être leur père jack et c'est cool
tu es plus je bois petit groupe était 4
gorges et psychologiquement chez camping
est ce que le goûter à ce que tim thomas
je me sens après infos que j'ai pu voir
sa cote est pas attendre comme sa pire
chose que jamais coupé
ben ouais même la bière les premières
photos
reconnaître les temps non pas du tout je
mettais tout tuer mais ce oui mais j'ai
apprécié quand même parce que bon jeu tu
n'as dure depuis j'ai entendu j'ai dans
ma vie plein de fois l'été les amalgames
les saveurs tout sauf si bas enfin quid
j'ai apprécié le goût quand même piste
et j'ai compris un peu le côté détente
ouais j'ai fait c'est ça qui me fait
flipper parce qu'apple goût c'est elle
qui était un gm serait téméraire j'aime
la vie manger ça a placé mais c'était
plus comme mais je voulais pas c'était
vraiment une fois cas parce que j'ai
compris l'effet de
ouais j'ai fait hausser ce que je veux
pas puis je veux pas boire ça au moment
où je vais avoir besoin t
je veux vraiment puisque logiquement
faire j'en ai juste envie là pas pour à
la gauche amen ou buncefield pauvreté je
veux pas que ça devienne une raison je
veux que ce soit sociabilité puis puis
fait que si c'est vrai que la petite île
à la petite bière de fin de journée le
camp qui est quand même aussi goûter ou
est ce que tu fais jusqu'à malsaine mais
une grosse plaie le petit cette année
comme ta récompense mais en même temps
il ya des gens qui te récompense dans
penthouse a peut être les bonbons est la
nourriture y est et après ça c'est juste
de déterminer de toi qu'est ce que tu
veux que ça soit de récompenses puis où
ça devient malsain le moi je suis
toujours dit et messieurs je me rappelle
j'ai appelé mon oncle qu'il fera mon
parent avec leurs proches que jamais
vraiment bu d'alcool non plus pour les
mêmes raisons antécédent familial
quelques mois de la même famille j'avais
dit j'aimais surtout il a été comme à
capo de police voient pas devenir
alcooliques petite école oui métier en
dresser sur l'eau quand on est sujet à
ce sujet soit le jeter comme je dois
penser d'un et ça tu montres d'acheter
donnera c'est comme si j'allais les
valises et un sac upa j'aimais bois ma
coupe devant et ça m'ennuie nom puis
igawa tu lui as à faire ça fait un an
que je bois une petite coupe de vin
comme ça puis la chute est apprécié et
c'est vraiment pour les bonnes raisons
au bon moment avec les amis tout ça mais
mais mais c'est drôle parce que
maintenant je me dis je recevais alloués
par match j'avais déjà marcher devant
moi j'ai
mes invités ou encore un verre d'eau et
de glace les invités comme les y amener
leurs alcools mais sherbrooke n'y a
toujours pas honorée dans la catégorie
mais ça j'arrête le réflexe pour moi
l'alcool c'est glacé doit passer le gag
parce que les commentaires avant un
bobard réflexion qu'ils habitent la côte
à la nage mais ce camp mais non le fusil
lauzon bell puis si j'ai envie je sais
ce que j'apprends a dealé avec ce tome
est et je vois pas m'acheter des caisses
de 12 bouteilles de voyages sécu jamais
en plus haut au début de la business ça
devait pas être calmes et ton talent et
chez les gens dans d'autres communes
comme une activité de commerce ou des
bouteilles puis on mange les bons sushi
pis si tu dois être comme ça très pas
mal
les clients toujours coupe devant une
meute et j'étais genre
l'âge éliminé au passage si les gens se
rendaient pas compte qu'ils aient
jamais su reconnaître
déjà mouillé mais les registres merci
merci m'étais mais c'est sûr que c'est
festif métier j'ai jamais vu en échange
ceux-ci xiam et ont par exemple on n'a
jamais vu oui on a plein d'histoires le
pouvais je vais faire un livre là-dessus
sur pleine affaire cocasse mais c'est
des affaires de foule de gens comme
complètement y va jamais vu piloter les
gestes un service qui se paye une
expérience vraiment à x ou
s'est relevé jusqu'aux des femmes
c'est un vrai projet c'est de faire un
livre sur des enfants qui sont pas fait
attendre car dès
publie jamais des histoires
primaire on a eu l'exclusivité ici là
ben oui j'en ai j'en ai jamais une
pauvre hère ca se reconnaît je ne peux
pas mais c'est pas grave
je vais toujours me rappeler j'étais à
québec puis à
cette époque là je parlais beaucoup avec
moi je parle tout le temps avec mon père
mais steam on part au début début même
si 12 allée parce que tu vas chez des
inconnus mais bon là je m'avance une
fille j'arrive là c'est super agréable
mais il fait noir que chez noir c'est
une belle journée d'été il à jean
grosselle est ce plus grande qui ces 100
mais c'est chaud et tia pas la clim ces
supports est tout simple le jeu rempli
est avec son ado genre de size acquis
comme vraiment à d'autres métiers que le
tibet comme un peu plus la marque et
comment c'était comme pas elle qui avait
organisé la soirée mais ça se passait
chez elle ok tu manges arrive dans jour
là j'ai des choses à faire avant que ça
devienne le sais j'ai beaucoup de nous
et de trucs afin que j'arrive je déballe
mais bâclé se barde apporte le jeu
commence à monter nous arrange pas par
nous chipent le thé le jeune vraiment il
se marre un peu à ouvrir les rideaux
pour deux lots l'oeil le t il faut
vraiment qu'il faudrait que totti qui a
un peu de lumière y amène la clim des
embauches me rappelle plein stade en
tenaille pour choix bien et puis bon il
fait son passé pilote qu'un livre où les
rideaux sur les moeurs de tout son
premier étage qui comme salon cuisine
typique petite maison et cuisine à aire
ouverte le bon salon guy il ya les mains
sont remplies de tout ce qui est
artistique de l'uqar communautaire
mais j'en retire comme ça c'est comme le
film avec comment que ça peut battre à
damas que robin williams y avait fait un
film sont obsédés une autre vieille
avait comme des des punaises qui reliait
pis des correspondances pilote d'accord
voilà qui a le fait alain genre en amour
akiyama moravie concessions mais c'est
un film c'est un vrai phénomène y en a
eu le bon goût et communiquer à l'aller
au procès à l'écouté en ligne mais après
tout dit en fait les amis organisent à
soirée pour changer d'idée ok sauf qu'il
ya un mois premier rang chez eux
gervais dit qu'ils se moquent tous comme
des légitimes défense
29 mai et est changeante et métiers
comme ta maman dany tu vis des champs
auspices et j'ai pas dans le jugement d'
par 2021 le mais j'ai été perturbé ma
place un rang contre taxe télécoms ont
un besoin d'haïti mais mais claire mas
et ses hôtes et fait que j'étais pas
qu'une heure comme dans ce contexte
vraiment très particulier avec l'ami de
l'hôtel arrive qu'ils fassent comme le
carol assez inaudibles on s'endort on va
prendre les rondes pour un petit ring il
a tout eu des 110 l'atmosphère est
devenue les gens qu'elle chante cité
c'est juste que cette femme-là avait à
ce moment là une obsession le mais j'ai
eu vraiment pas comment est menotté
parce que j'étais comme j'avais texter
mon père je me rappelle que mon
blackberry pas un genre et à quelle
adresse j'étais à québec noter quelques
indiens promener le genre le juste vu sa
part le moteur
5 hier mais j'ai pas vraiment d'épisodes
de où j'ai eu par le tri j'ai une une
dame qui s'est mis à parler de ma mère
décédée gens râlent entendait le live le
tissu c'était capoté parce que mme amara
venait tout juste de décéder petit si je
t'ai pas mais sushis dans stahl il y
avait rien qui était sorti à mon sujet
mais moi je faisais mes petites soirées
bouche à oreille j'avais même pas
instagram exister postes en 2010 le
genre fait que oui je reste à g
fact et puis je me rappelle dans la
cuisine d'enfants met
en avant qui est gros terrain qu'il a
commencé à me dire jean ben écoute
geneviève tamar est ici alors à 7 par
les brèches comme
pendant quelques mois mais c'est seul
dans le fond un a fait dire que telle
affaire pierre mascitti des affaires
quand même assez particulière que juste
moi puis maman on ne vit qu'une heure
sur deux médiums la grande et ben en
fait à tisser genre conseillère en
pharmaceutique la madame au seti a dit
m'excuse lampard l'âme dictée quêter à
défaut je te parle t elle c'est même peu
comme moi de ce que j'ai vécu mais elle
s'était même pas si c'était même pas
sorti une boule de cristal ou des cartes
l'été jeu ça me parle ils ont en
revanche il n'y avait pas d'argent non
plus
mais oui c'est bien a dit des choses qui
étaient quand même troublant sens que
ma mère dans sa chambre quelques heures
avant de mourir la version bouquet de
roses parce que l'île d'orléans fournit
la maison michel sarrazin québec en
bouquets pour que les gens en fin de vie
puisqu'ils qui aime plus fort bond qui
m'a ravi qui a toujours été du site
parce que limite camac apprenait en fin
de vie c'était la drogue qui apprennent
au quotidien fac
c'est des doses un peu plus intense mais
était quand même là à qui on donnait les
roses parce qu'elles peuvent en profiter
pour vrai parce qu'ils étaient pas
d'impact puis m avait dit en mai train
dans ton char c'est comme si signe de
protection ma mère mon auto je les ai
beaucoup de route à l'époque je restais
à penetanguishene fa cup à
birmingham avait dit m e de rose dans
son auto c'est la dame chez eux qui a
diarra t'oublie de mettre la rose dans
ton genre
voudrait imposer
comme ok bagarre ça s'est passé lopy
sais c'est impossible qu'à sa chaussure
jetée comme bas et ça je me dis ça donne
auriez mais partout
pourquoi tu au bien-être
des cdi j'avais affaire à jerry tgp a
pas de soi - c'est tout moi qui a
orchestré puis j'avais pas beaucoup de
sous fax et des demandes d'aidé pour les
funérailles réputé c'est compliqué le
canton pas les moyens à clamecy au tpiy
ma mère m'avait dit aussi je vais
toujours être dans ton auto pas ce
moment là jamais conduit jeu mme amara à
m'avait dit mais toi tu fais beaucoup de
route parce que je sais à peine prochain
puis en avait besoin est aussi loin que
l'on est non le nom et la firme avait
dit être toujours dans ton charge de
protéger moi j'ai toujours pensé qu'il
était sèche passagers ça fait dix ans et
il a la dame la voyante hamdi tu penses
que tu as marre un siège passager à
admin on est en arrière blanchet comment
pourquoi ces hadiths et son chauffeur
privé
c'est comme ma marque était en ruines
dans une autre vie le genre presque la
fac à terme a dit des choses que je pige
à remercier encore aujourd'hui 6 jeudi
je me demande pas si c'est vrai ou pas
vrai je les véhicules à pile tu es un
bon moment ça me fait du bien ça m'a
donné plein d'énergie puis en garde peu
importe je me suis pas posé la question
que j'ai vécu le moment tout comme comme
quand j'étais arrivé chez un client qui
avait une fine couche à table j'étais
obligé de m me maquille de sutter
manuvie les choses catastrophe se pose
pas de question et
[Musique]
une fille nue couchée femme est arrivée
genre dans soit aurait parce que au
début moi je fais me maquille pts puis
amendé je commence à plein été mais
maquis dans les assiettes pile gueule et
vin blanc mais pas ceux d'alsace et puis
tout cuisine
ça sera pas là et il était vraiment
rohff un peu le stade des gars qui
travaillaient dans le web
mais
si la seule et unique fois dans tout il
ya à peu près une cinquantaine de
soirées sushi à la maison par semaine 52
semaines par année au quai puis c'est la
première fois où
c'est très rare qui ajuste des god of
war
a dû en arriver là mais ils taisent pas
sympathiques je n'avais pas par quoi que
ce soit fac bref un climat qui plaide
comme normal on pas là dessus mais ça
qu'on y apporte est aussi zabel doué à
la gare l'autre frenchie colts mais pas
leur détresse la banque contente d'être
là ça casse est allongé ici la sq en
outaouais
uqo ok mais moi mon plat mais dans ma
tête et mes plateaux me maquille bon les
maquis free sort dans l assiette le
maillot nike bagdam le must c'est
maintenant moi je vais brûler pauvre
fille segedema quichaud la
spa genre hey sexy de ces 10 avec des
sashimis la sottoli d'animaux luxor
lighting desjouis moi c'est vraiment ma
marque de commerce et les plateaux
ghoumal fils de cheikh en baisse avec
une demoiselle gauche
[Rires]
j'ai été chanceux pourquoi j'avais des
petites feuilles de bananes dans les
bacs fois que j'ai pu utiliser stop pour
cacher puis paul a brûlé et puis bon ça
que je me bats de la mayo excellent son
nombril tout le monde est encore temps
c'est là là ça c'est qu'un mois jean les
véhicules ne
comprend pas ce qu'est ma business ça
existe pas le comme un service de chef à
vizille domaine qui est pas exprès avec
un resto très souvent c'est des restos
et arrive avec la pub de fait mais y en
a pas beaucoup qui ont fait tout sur
place surtout en sushi pizza mais de
plus en plus mais bref bien sûr tout à
cette époque leçon veux je prends comme
j'avais huit cents ans mais bon puis
effectivement mes filles on se parle le
même langage le canton fait déporter
parce que on vit tout les mêmes parfait
robin team les gens qui nous réserve
mais c'est qu'ils restent à au sixième
étage pas d'ascenseur avec nos bas côté
c'est correct le fait pisser betchine
métier on a tellement d'histoires à
raconter le des enfants vivent nos
chalets on a toutes les commodités n'y a
pas d'eau courante et camions c'est sûr
tu n'y as vosges à ma vaisselle en
cuisine du cru si je me suis déjà
évanoui chez un client pas j'allais
acheter des vertiges positionnelle des
fois on est arrivé à une journée où je
me suis évanoui dans la cuisine du
client est parti en ambulance à charles
ix prennent encore
bosser ça s agit là dimanche à tours et
on est donc bien les
gains des suppléments calais quand tu
étais ministre ont des contrats mais
tombe pilote du patch très têtu un peu
ces soirées là têtus mais pour le mans -
mais notre jeu repose ma question qui me
dire comment cela évolue filston mais
têtue un peu stand by de comme il doit
apporter baroin de téléphone s'il ya
quelque chose qui se passe des lol
encore aujourd'hui ah oui best fc comme
maternité surdéveloppement adjointe
toute loterie si on est vraiment deux
dans la business et moi c'est moi qui le
crée un système arrivé longtemps après
mais était maintenant je peux plus vivre
sans ça elle parce qu'on se complète
vraiment ça mouzannar dans l'entreprise
puis on vient de grossir l'équipe
administrative ce qu'on était juste deux
affaires tout 6 à 9 euros le reste assez
ça me rappelle mon souci c'est comme
pilote a dit moi je suis comme il ya
quelque chose qui cloche comme souvent
brûlés ou la finale ma vie j'arrose
engagé genre de nouvelles personnes avec
des dt des tubes très précieux qu'est ce
que
c'est six mois
quelque chose qui cloche je fasse deux
couples s'étaient clairement sommet bref
puis oui c'est quand même à tout les
jours sur tous ces temps-ci l'été avec
le retour des soirées dix personnes dans
la maison vin d'orge s'il y en a eu lieu
en inde où dimanche des soirées touche à
la maison jamais vécu seul
combien de soirée par semaine nous
permettre d'envisager mois et demi ce
souci par son pendant la pandémie t en
et que se sont réorientés petite toupie
n'importe qui est du problème de main
d'oeuvre en ce moment mais est il en ce
moment je pense qu'on ait fait une
vingtaine sur la route mais qui est ce à
peu près une cinquantaine de soirées par
semaine ah ouais c'est un siège et des
miss qui travaillent merci les filles
six jours semaines c'est ainsi le fond
des traitements à tous les obsèques si
jal a fait l'appel clients le matin ou
encore le menu puis les menus de 2008 le
lait mai 2021 parce qu'elle est
peut-être des particularités à tout le
monde quelque chose puis on s'adapte du
mieux qu'on peut puis on fait vraiment
notre possible la presse avant les peas
qui après son embauche et clients et pas
assez de chez vous
dans le fond les miss tout pas de 100
watts à toi tu fais venir tout cas force
est originaire chaque miss vocaloid
chercher le stock ne résoud rien est ce
qu'il ya de tout le temps tout ce qu'il
faut tout fait pour menus en fonction ce
qui est d'un mois j'ai inventé toutes
les manifs touche à la maison avec
qu'est ce qui se trouve facilement pour
mes miss tout le temps parce que sont
partout au québec je trouvais ça dommage
que quelqu'un abitibi vivent pas la même
soirée kaki à montréal qu'à montréal
je suis un moment donné c'est pas
acheter c'est pat standardisé mais
d'offrir le même service à tout le monde
verra que sa côte nord dans le bas du
fleuve vient des géo extra inventé à
partir de quesques usa chez iga extra je
te prie j'ai extrait parce que mes
produits sont en vente la met au centre
avait
dit c'est ça fait que dans le fond moi
j'ai tout consumant menus enfants ne
sont pas que les filles à tout les
matins ils vont chercher leurs affaires
et oui on achète des trucs en plus gros
dans les magasins et asiatiques
clairement mais tout le frente aux
voleurs qui se pare pierres puis
vraiment c'est super facile c'est pour
les filles chaque cas précis ça tu vas
chez tonkam le tir est tapé ses pilotes
et était le maître d'hôtel l'actuel
service tête c'est
c'était le thème est gentil fax est
vraiment exigeant avec la ces temps-ci
travail si george orwell mais qui aime
et on est tout le temps là oui ok bing
maps steph parce que c'est paru plein
d'affaires mais c'est surtout si le
canton de qualité à d'autres les gens
moi je peux pas chez les gens comment je
fais pour savoir si on fait des sondages
on n'a pas une façon mais c'est ils
m'envoient des photos dans vos des
vidéos de ce qu'ils font à leur table et
leur portion nombre de m'acquitter sa
cliente avait des moyens ne manquent et
je vais aller voir les photos je pouvoir
compter enfin elle c'est vrai il avait
fait oublier une sortie ah oui c'est
vrai c'est pour ce quart n'ont manqué là
je peux ou ben non on avait vraiment y
était vraiment juste glouton activement
à donner avec ses contrôles qualité
aussi fait qu on est tout le temps le
mois piste et a fait quoi qui arrive le
tout la baisse touche à la maison c'est
ma ville c'est le fram monfils oui dans
cette dans cette entreprise l'oeuf cette
croissance le
yacht eu des moments où s'étaient sentis
comme au royaume part
parce qu'ils se qui a géré ce qui s'en
vient au bateau tu es quelqu'un qui est
vraiment capable de genre compartiment
palliser les choses régler un dossier
fermer cette porte leur ouvrir une copie
comme cartésienne mans avant six mois
mais j'ai vraiment bonne pour
compartimenté dans ce volet là de ma vie
c'est ouais j'suis pas la même personne
personnellement
non mais personnellement je suis plus
sensible jeu plus atteignable mais au
niveau de mon travail qui est ma
business qui est la chose que je
maîtrise le mieux au monde je capable
vraiment de compartimenter oui puis non
je me suis jamais sentie comme et tout
fait sauf récemment parce que j'ai
commencé à vendre des franchises j'avais
du temps libre pendant la pandémie mais
il ya pas un meilleur moment pour
acheter une franchise qui en pleine
pandémie quand les restaurants sont
fermés
vraiment bien puis je suis pas fier mais
en fait moi c'est encore comme je le dis
- rien de prémédité moi quand j'ai
ouvert mon premier comptoir d'un flag
j'avais juste je vais économiser pour
boire toute ma vie
je me suis toujours investi et moi du
moment où j'ai fait du profit avec
souchez à la maison c'est à dire ma
première soirée ou charge et 5 $ par
personne
un mystérieux dollarama me racheter des
bols charger sa voiture chargée pour
simi d'un clip sim était que je n'ai pas
payé pas montamisé meego développé non
c'était juste comme un pourboire quoi
que ce soit je me rappelle les premières
fois que j'ai fait des sous avec souche
à la maison j'ai pas été il m'a acheté
quoi que ce soit le talent et racheter
des bols parce que j'ai il m'a manqué
hier j'ai toujours réinvestis enfin
quand même encore aujourd'hui quand j'ai
ouvert mon premier contrôle chez raison
c'était même pas j'ai amené y est
question de budget j'ai pas fait
d'études de marché j'ai pas fait de pas
fait de prêt à la banque lemagit au
corps près je dois rien à personne
puis il avait dissous plus tu ben moi je
prouverai rencontre ça serait bon pour
le brent ça fait travailler les gens je
pourrai manger le tartare quand j'en
habite à côté de chez nous c'est juste
fort encore une fois bien gourmande puis
la pression j'ai ouvert québec parce que
j'ai rentabilisé rapidement montréal
parce que ça va bien pc on eyed peas et
banquise les gourmands puis la presse
aux belles eaux pendant la pandémie
jetés comme des princes j'avais dit j'ai
des centaines de messages dans la vôtre
courriels de gens qui en veulent mais
j'avais pas d'acheter comme non non non
j'ai partage pas ce que je fais pas ça
carbure paul cache web avant des
franchises moi c'était comme un manche
c'est pas seul à vocation spéciale but
en vert c'est quoi qui drive en fait
c'est dans l'entrepreneuriat c'est pas
le cacher c'est quoi le moteur sinon mon
mais ma passion pour la bouffe qui voir
les gens aimés puis entendre avoir des
messages de gens j'ai mangé costumes aux
affres et encore nico on fait le même
changement pupu c'était délicieux où
c'est par travailler des gens c'est de
faire c'est faire ma marque et faire mon
empreinte partager c'était vraiment
sauté comme tout le monde on veut gagner
notre ville pour lutter je veux dire on
se le cachera pas mais il ya géo quand
vous pourrez demander à mon équipe j'ai
déjà mais aucun calcul qui est fait moi
je comme je commence à vous comme tu es
mon avocat pour les franchises ou juste
pour commencent à voter
ça vaut quand même c'est lui qui me l'a
dit parce qu on est dans des trucs
standardisée de ces familles comme voici
selon tomber en savent autant même où
c'est lui qui me le dit mais je je
savais même pas comment je vais aller
jusqu'à ce que je le demanderai sa menti
parce que moi je fais mes affaires ça
c'est le fun métis et comme je ne sais
pas ce que je fais c'est gentil je me
rends même pas compte mais combien
combien d'overland or là parfois de fait
comme qu'aimer
c'est où nous mettons séoul était tout
ce
bois est exactement mais tu es là tu
fais juste faire des affaires puis j'ai
décidé de faire un combat sont tranchées
dit d'y aller avec des anciennes les
sushis qui avaient envie d'évoluer dans
la business des pics sont tous voir des
comptoirs puis quand l affaire de
famille c'est comme je m'étais créé une
famille c'est pierre aujourd'hui avec
les franchisés mais combien
contenté hier matin hier matin à
gatineau siffle contente d'ailleurs en
primeur pour moi c'est une vraie
cata ya six mois que vous êtes content
j'ai signé hier avec une pierre laurent
mais moi je suis en fait de fellering
pour prier je t'avais dans le bourg dans
sa maison à l'autre bout du monde c'est
un val-des-monts pilot est amorcé qu'un
petit bob lipica comme j'avais la
convention mais je fais comme si je vais
par la guerre je me
marierai nos
confrères oui fais-moi transfert non moi
c'est un enfer du moins si j'avais senti
qu'ils étaient moindres ma kou kou
j'aurais fait
si chaud car participer parce que je ne
fais pas pour ça je veux vraiment
travaille déjà avec kiss avec le fon de
faire un chalet fois par année puis
qu'on va avoir du fun et moi je vois
juste le plaisir et la communication
aussi c'est la chose la plus importante
est parce qu on se parle tous les jours
moi puis mes franchisés mais les sushis
ou du barca est pas tous les jours mais
je veux dire on finit par son talent au
moins une fois par semaine un mois ou
stéphanie pu taxer ces facteurs on est
en hausse de 4 franchisés et de à moi
c'est ça va se marier le meti gmp temps
de répondre à tout le monde qu'ils
m'envoient des miens pour en avoir ces
têtes et temis sushi puis elle est bleue
maintenant les franchises rives dos et
ça pourrait pas être une représentation
plus directe de tomblaine l'apec le
monde qui vont ses filles lors qu'ils
sont sur la route où les gens qui vont
une tranchée jeudi ils deviennent là ils
deviennent tomberait
viennent moi c'est ça qui m'a angoissé
quand poser la question c'était et et
owen mois ci mais oui parce que la moins
chère maison c'est elle qui était elle
sait on va chez les jeunes ya pas très
fier que c'est pas d'accord c'est
fâcheux comme 78 cents à pul sur la
pelouse de soirée samedi je veux
travailler et et j'ai toujours besoin
d'avoir une porte de sortie moi je me
lèverai l'humain que je suis j'ai besoin
d'avoir un plan b c d pour me sauver mes
pommes sauver genre je regarde plus
derrière geste houle était juste pour
faire ok si ça me tente plus je peux
faire aussi mais pour moi c'est sûr
exact mais puis le depuis récemment j'ai
vendu ma première franchise il n'y a
même pas une halle mais elle le tout et
semaine mais comme hey c'est quoi le
monde est debout il atteindrait 7
pourquoi bien je ferai mais moins que
dans mon bureau pourquoi
ben mhenni concorde lakhdarchaouche
monsieur je suis vraiment eu de feeling
cpi-m woippy nicolas duvernois on se
parlait l'auto qui ont traité un peu
d'entrepreneurs bibitte parce que on ne
peut plus de même ses avoirs face au
hall of fame sont incorrectes et puis on
y va avec comme notre fils il n'obtient
pas un pays ne rien calculer un tableau
excel par mon poney tableau excel oui je
connais pas ces tableaux etc pas d'étude
de marché pas de nom mais quels seraient
les franchisés s'ils veulent enfin
pardon et enfin meetic ans je sais que
ça va marcher comme dépense pour 7000 $
pour te faire dire la même affaire que
je tenterai nausée je vous hais ce mot
instagram puis même des plateformes
qu'il ya des gens qui vont y aller comme
de faire jusqu'à maintenant ça me met
pas marty mas plateforme c'est les gens
avec qui j'ai le plus pur étroitement
projetées qui consomment les affaires
fait que jacques gatineau c'est le
plateau et ça va être marrant c'est au
tpi tu dis que tu es tu nous fais de
filins puis jeter autant dans business
quinqua mettons tu fais pour le moment
pas d'étude de marché que ça va marcher
pour écrire etc raison que je pense de
s'informer par
ou où les gens que tu emploies tillim
l'image de cet état revers n'est pas
fils est quelqu'un de fort aubin selon
le cv jeu quand même l'employé plus
différent de nous avec des caractères
moins compatibles
il y en aura toujours pour madame x
fabricant nec sont plus à y maintenaient
dessous que j'aurai vécu jadis mais tu
dis la personne et travaillante est
dévouée tutu talent une personnalité et
son veau juste essayé de conjuguer
toutes s'appuient parce que si ce pas
elle s'en est une autre je dirai au
courant de ma carrière j'ai employé bien
des gens des fois ça fitte et des fois
ça fitte et paul hamon a donné tout le
monde essaye de faire du mieux pour que
sa fille depuis tant mieux si ça marche
tant pis tant pis ça marche pas pas
grave si on continue tout notre bout de
chemin dans le monde environ vie nos
enfants c'est comme j'ai reçu des
démissions récemment parce que les gens
ils changent de ces ben correct et puis
à chaque fois c'est comme jean rex comme
non je fous le contente pour toi tu t'en
vas faire quelque chose que tu aimes
plus ou que tu as envie de faire ou un
rail vous ça m'a donné faut pas le
prendre personnel qu'il faut faire du
mieux quand on vit avec des humains de
ces petits bosquets pas bien respect par
exemple c'est une chose s'est il fait là
pour toi le moi je moi j'aime ce que je
fais si tu vient entacher ma passion
parce que toi tu es malheureuse
malheureux là on peut sans discuter je
te souhaite vraiment mieux tiré mais moi
personnellement j'aime vraiment ce que
je t ai fait que je fais ce que je veux
du mieux que je peux pour del avec
toutes sortes de personnalités qui
valent la peine de prendre le temps d
apprendre d apprivoiser puis des fois un
moment donné c'est surtout ça
c'est des gens il vend bien et puis tout
sport que plus ça devient grosse de plus
en plus difficile de garder la dnp le
sens de ce que c'était la base puis de
toi ta personnalité caracas en transpire
dans toutes les branches pitié dans tout
les comptoirs petit j'en veux pas j'en
veux pas une centaine moi j'aspire pas
devenir n'aimerais pas de bannière là
mais j'aspire pas de
oui c'est ça mais c'est très correct
célestin est une formule qui fonctionne
pis c'est parfait moi j'en ai pas envie
parce que je veux pas cannibaliser mon
service à domicile non plus c'est moi
j'ai des mises sous chipie sujet à la
maison mon service à la maison c'est mon
bébé est ce que les comptoirs c'est un
nouveau bébé qui est arrivé des années
plus tard oui mais ton premier c'est un
procès c'est ce qui a permis tout le
reste c'est bach ma franchise et la
kippa consciente de son bain c'est pas
ma franchise et parce que si affaibli
son foot émises l'an jamais le saas
pourrait comme différer la mer en moi
protéger ses petits non pas que pour ce
que j'en veux à des endroits
stratégiques qui vont justifier la
cliente qui attend sa soirée avec tout
ça va être comme ergonomique si on veut
puisqu'il va toutes ses agences et puis
tu es je pense pas que je vaux dilué ma
personnalité parce que c'était même dans
le document de franchisés mais valeur sa
première page c'est quoi je m'attends
pis comment est-ce que c'est la
gourmandise plus que content et ico aspi
s'assurer qu'on fit non que je voyais un
maquis grognements foule acclamant soit
pas spécial cette semaine mon mac il ya
gourmands puis les clients qui me
revenaient parce que gourmands c'est cet
appel parce que si plus petits
m'inquiéter quantité initiale mais c'est
moi je suis gourmand s'est scellée clé
mais les filles le savent pas quand tu
veux une franchise succès que faut pas
que tu comptes faut que ce soit généreux
les cercles sa clientèle évidemment le
jeu pas besoin de le dire marcos et
c'est clair qu'on est celle dont on
n'échappe toutefois pas rentable c'est
la vie on peut pas par le monde mais on
fait tout et puis autant pour le service
à la maison qu'elle est comtois puis
c'est ma personnalité paie cash
je tranche et les sushis ou au comptoir
j'essaie de me voir on peut à travers
elle au site et je dors à s'adapter fac
je sais qu'ils vont pouvoir transmettre
ça quand ils sont en cuisine déjà mais
peu partout ben c'est ce que toi tu en
fais pur non sens nuit à tulle étant
quelqu'un qui vous qui voulait que ce
soit toile on espérait que cet arrêt ici
comme avant l'heure isabelle quand
j'allais chez eux le has avait projeté
qui était malade était comme on en passe
et ça c'est mon beau frère là ils
totalisent 2 c'est ce que j'aime et
c'est d'avoir tout à prouver de faire un
thème prête à repartir mauvais mon
gérant pense pas que la grosse cuillère
japonaise en arbre dans la bouche en
train de manger de temps dans votre thé
borgias mais oui c'était du tarp à c'est
moi c'est ce que j'aime mettre ces mets
ont fait redécouvrir mais maintenant les
jeunes connexes à beignon des attentions
leur moi j'aimais seule espèce de paver
la route de salles et vous c'est quoi
pour vous montrer c'est quoi quand il
chante freecom chaufferie ben voyons oui
mais je me dis tard par dessus le m
voyant dans pile si j'aimais ce avoir
tout à prouver qu'ils personnes savez je
sais qui mais là j'ai pu faire mon
travail quand je me suis jamais c'est un
autre copie et je me plais pas merci
mais si je peux pas la cuisine basque
ils veulent me parler épis sont quand
même et l'eau est chez nous l'horrible
mémo si je content de ma place que je
fais si je veux je veux cracher des
parités mama fort à table ouais mais là
c'est pas un terme à mes soucis
d'accès différents mais je m'ennuie de
nostalgie pour l'époque où j'avais tout
à prouver puis j'ai encore plein de
choses à prouver mais de façon
différente
mais mais j'aimais ça vraiment
impressionner les gens l'opt et moi je
faisais tu interroges alimenter mes
racines chez les gens notre tâche et
nous lé s'est fait que la
meilleure façon de savoir si s'il reste
le plateau parce que
ça jamais arrivé où c'était comme un
flop total en allemangne h he le boucher
m'étais jeté car à qui on est au moins
où j'aurais pu mettre ce serait plus
poignée où je prenais le commentaire le
live la cuisine déjà été fait mais j'ai
jamais rien tester d'avancer encore
aujourd'hui bien vendre dans ma partie
shoot toi toi même temps quand tu donnes
nouveau menu atémis lehoux a été
franchie je suppose je sais pas comment
ça fonctionne dans ce sens là mais
est-ce que tu les tests tous les tests
toi même chez vous a jamais tu attends
vols maintenus tout est fait sur puis
dites moi qu'est ce qu'ils montrent pas
10 mais dans les livres les magazines
j'invente sur place the good the bad &
fois la géopolitique bien pour la photo
parce qu'elle l'a jeté comme un nom
jérémy de lyon lada lors des combats en
vol mais mars est à propos de l'épidémie
on en reste et ça ferait pas ça papote
au fait que l'on rajoute des sous à ses
plus hauts niveaux des épices seul un
petit peu comme être ajustés la photo il
sait manier frei sa part a comparé leur
métier non je veux tout dans ma tête
tout le temps qui c'est moi qui invente
99.9 pour samedi afin qu'un décret au
livre de recettes j'étais sur l'écrit à
main levée à la légère ces seules
affaires chez blizzard ge est il
maintenant on en parlait de toi tu as
écris tout temps manuscrit pour
l'envoyer ils ont shooté ils ont goûté à
ouais c'est vrai c'est bon pour moi je
cuisine regard ris je me fais des lignes
directrices la matin olive sushis mais
je fais des sushis vous achetez un mac
intel à faire le j'accuse et en plus je
le goûte le hawzi parfait on va la
mettre dedans on peut la photographier
et c'est bon et bien on est toutes
ensemble c'est mon frère est une fois
puisqu'il le goûter le projet et qui
n'appliquent jamais testé pascal premier
livre sur tout open certes c'est souvent
celui qui se vend le plus en plus c'est
un petit peu quel
est l'autre les moyens plus en plus j'ai
pas la photo du maquis je n'avais pas
les moyens de m'acheter la bouffe
d'épicerie pour faire toutes les
recettes y en avait mais dansant ou 85
fax dépôt fait je les goûters dans ma
tête avec des fois je me sors jamais
sans leur faire le 1 pour d'avoir des
photos pour chacun mais enfin il ya
plein de fois où vous sa patte et puis
de manger j'étais quand même dans ce
sens et bon ben si c'est possible parce
que ma mère et on le dit et sans
recettes le site veut vraiment les faire
goûter au complet les refaire encore
amélioré clair faire une troisième fois
pour la photo un ça va te prendre quatre
enfants
camani kitano city mois-ci spontanéité
défaut jusqu'au bout à cette recette là
je leur ferai pas me tombait était
vraiment bon mais l'hôte et jauge tant
mieux vu j'ai pas envie de la manger où
on le trouve urbaine ont fait l'agent du
fbi a mené ses devoirs aussi qu'est ce
que les gens veulent puis tout seul qui
facture mais pour une fois ça m'arrive
plus souvent qu'autrement d'inventer
dans ma peine d'essayer fort oui des
fois ci les filages comment gouttes dans
un aussi bon ah oui elle fait des fois
même aux surprises comme à l'ouest elles
huit ont préféré et oui partant de boeuf
le chorizo tech rage comme ok cool mais
les affranchis cuisine des choses que
j'aime pas aussi parce qu'elle en est il
peut pas cuisiner juste pour moi
fait que les filles y goûte son commerce
ou et c'est ça c'est bon le cpie le coût
des fois mais moi j'aurai pas passé
c'était elle qui allait être le plus
populaire des leaders de notre combi
jusqu'à mais j'en ai dit tantôt douce
plus le magazine emploi ce qg quatre
magazines par année mais là c'est la
première année que l'on emprunte de les
magazines trois stars à la fin du mois
d'août qui est en train de faire le
magazine de nouère dance machine
étonnante est bien honnête elle jamais
un point qui comme bon
j'en ai fait un mot
juste des maquis t on tard par poké
d'hommes ligne son propre peuple
inspiration asiatique bâti comme si
j'essaye un peu de mettre ma touche pitt
et de ne pas approprié que ce soit ont
essayé de vraiment tout faire évoluer en
fait la cuisine on n'invente rien on
réinvente qu'on essaie de mettre notre
grain de sel puis c'est vraiment ma
ligne directrice que j'essaie de ne pas
trop déranger je me suis dit je veux pas
me mélanger à travers des très bons qui
existant déjà fax comme j'essaie
vraiment de garder ma ligne directrice
moins d'une fois de temps en temps
mettre un petit truc plus déjà ma cote
pour le moment à 6 ans je vais aller
chercher de langage n'avoir besoin que
je veux pas avoir honte de son passé
manifs et j'en ai vente anticipée c'est
ici un magasin de ses 65 j'en ai quatre
par année je fais au moins livres par
année elle était plus en or syrie ou à
des projets
safran va être 3 424 kazim a des fois le
fait que le ch comme pour le moment ça
vaut mais je sais que je vais avoir
besoin et by toma dim mais je veux
enlever le flag puis je vois bien bien
avec ce team je dois le faire à montréal
mon resto vegan préféré ses sushis au
moule on est déçu
sans parler toi c'est quelque chose que
tu penses que tu dirais si le gameplay
on avait g vegan j'essaie de faire mon
possible de par un peu ma ligne
directrice tout ce
métier on a toujours à montréal surtout
petit il faut pas oublier ses traits
niche et non mais
si jamais je vais me faire manger
demande et du faux fromages menu complet
pour 5 % de la population
si tu perds un peu de vent qui était de
savoir real mais les alternatives si on
est du chômage on est donc moi je veux
jouer une soirée touché à la maison
vegan tu fais pas ce jeu ma jeunesse a
pour savez gamme on peut on peut parce
qu'on sait que ça va être isolées
puissent avec l'été on n'aura pas tous
espèrent ne sais pas vous n'êtes pas
dans votre époque vous êtes tant que
soient pas nombreux métiers je voudrais
ça reste quand même c'est très niche et
y mettez votre sur la scène façon de
fait notre première soirée lockers parce
que tu es jeta ses bonnes là dedans
aussi pis ça a un peu changé aussi ma
façon à moi le maniement des petits
tapis ça a fait ça bien été les factions
s'adapter on s'est défaussé isolé puis
oui c'est d'adaptation pour mes miss
parce qu'ils étaient pour acheter les
produits c'est oui ça coûte plus cher
parce que nous nos bacs on a toutes nos
affaires mais tu es comme des allergies
graves gens aillent oignons le 6e dans
tout ça qui apprennent à faire qu'il
faut s'adapter il faut comprendre la
réalité puis c'est nos coupes supprimer
miss c'est leur gagne pain là mais où on
essaie d affaires maintenant catherine
sorita constat quand même ce qui donne à
voir 2 3 les rejets qu'un vegan un peu
de lutte n ainsi un subtil faut que tu
ouais ça pour tout et c'est pas quand
cédé à l'ag très graves ou mortelles
long on dit à la personne de de se
commander et et je dois m'en donner on
peut pas prendre le risque on est chez
vous on n'est pas dans un environnement
contrôlé si nicole à l'est de la
chapelure de pain une copie qui est ôtée
coeliaque depuis tout petit on ne peut
pas prendre de chance dès fois pitt ont
fait signer des décharges aussi parce
que déjà ça comment jeter hors jeu quand
même mais moi j'ai pareil mais étaient
moins taxées on s'adapte mais pauvre et
mes filles sont extraordinaires comme
c'est vraiment un tetris moi dans mon
temps car s'était dissout arrive à temps
plein y'avait pas d'allergie il y avait
à peine de vg il y avait il y avait
c'est vraiment spécial mais aujourd'hui
mais les gens selva et remplacement fait
que c'est beaucoup d'adaptation mais y
arrivent très bien mais frissons bah
ouais non nées des alternatives en au
menu trois ans et ça ça mais moi ça
m'intéresse je vais regarder ça me met
enfin apprécier ça
bravo pour vrai c'est incroyable ce que
tu construis était vraiment être pas par
étapes pierre par pierre leur site on de
faire ça tout seul au début les chez les
gens pilotes après l'expiration les
comptoirs sur les livres c'est vraiment
à en disant à peu près
c'est quand même incroyable
et puis moi ce qui m'impressionne le
plus
c'est le mentionné plus tôt c'est-à-dire
débrouillardise les incroyables noter
que ce que tu as réussi à construire
tout ce juste par instinct et whip it et
au travers de mon par contre mon madani
et déjà qu'ils soient comme un être pas
forcément c'est normal parce que tu vis
ta vie du fesfop la princesse a quand
même mais ça prend un permis pour stop
ça prend ainsi plus avec les années mais
là moi j'avais plein de travailleuses
autonomes années j'avais trop tard et
autonome jeter comme belge fera quoi
raconte avec un mais non mais là il faut
qu' il faut que sans registre il faut
que ça devienne des travailleurs
autonomes et avec des business plans la
platé m'a donné un titre suit le courant
ptc c'est aussi si j'avais tout étudier
ce que ça m'aurait pris j'aurais jamais
fait alors oui c'est ça les gens
entrepreneurs et des âmes et le jeu
comme tu penses trop si tu veux être
entrepreneur faute de soins et sociale
va apprendre aux gens il ya trois lacs
ouest qui voit débarquer que votre nom
c'est un moment donné de ton bon vouloir
oui les lois doivent être respectées
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que tu es
un moment donné mais non ça serait mieux
de faire seulement il nous faut
s'adapter ouais ça prend un autre mode
de fonctionnement tout ça mais on
l'apprend l'heure c'est quand dans le
camp essentiellement tout juste envie de
vivre de ta passion pour créer quelque
chose mais après ça les gens autour de
toi m'ont juste donner des perches pour
frey ou un sommet mme pitt et moi c'est
ce qui est arrivé bien des façons de
fonctionner qui sont plus les mêmes
qu'au début parce que la vie est ce
qu'elle est à l'avant ça évolue des fois
il ya des lois qui était pas le quilliec
appareils sa manette et comment up face
à ces faux pas quand tu veux partir de
business et faut que tu sois un souci un
pique nique laisse guider pic tu le
fasses pis c'est sur ton entourage va
décourager parce qu'il ferait jamais ça
et combien de fois alors il faut aller
chez le montrent des chiffres
ouvert c'est une impression qui est très
autant que par le maître dans sa
jeunesse il fallait que des bruits le
temps un peu tout seul pas à cause des
parents et en ce qu'ils étaient et c'est
que
que ça le fait qu'ils étaient entrés par
l'enquêté ah ben c'est sûr là bas je
pense que j'étais un peu génétiquement
aussi entreprenante que de noms passés
tous des entrepreneurs pitié je sais
qu'il ya quelque chose à moi qui est une
fibre entrepreneuriale que je n'avais
jamais dit que j'ai découvert au moment
où j'ai décidé de partir en affaires
mais c'est sûr qu'avec mon bagage
ça fait probablement de moins
de bruit la première entrepreneurs parce
que je suis pas parfaite mais j'aimerais
pouvoir parler à tout mon monde à tous
les jours pour lui dire qu'ils sont bons
picqué estime que je les remercie de
réaliser mon rêve mais c'est difficile
la vie d'un village et organiser la vue
qu'on peut se rassembler j'ai des pistes
porté à gauche à droite avec mes équipes
me contente je peux les voir mais c'est
mais je fais du mieux que je peux comme
un parent comme un humain et
l'inhumanité derrière mon ordi puis je
veux juste partager ma passion puis je
fais du mieux que je peux puis oui mon
bagage je me donne certaines expertises
bwin résilience beaucoup mais j'apprends
tous les jours vraiment des gens qui
m'entourent puis je m'entoure de
meilleur que moi pour certaines choses
parce que faut pas avoir peur de ça
parce que c'est tout le monde au leur
thé expertise puis leur savoir qu'ils
ont grandi ensemble le thé est ce que tu
décroches
de tous ceux où la business prend toute
la place dans ton cerveau mais je me
permets plus de décrocher parce que j'ai
une bonne équipe avec moi mettez ça
parce qu'il ya une affaire aussi c'est
comme quand moi je décroche met tout
dedans cours desquelles cadeau ça qui
est quand même à côté de moi qui comme
je sais que j'ai tout misé sur les
épaules de quelqu'un qui dit oui à son
salaire mais ce pas c'est mais je
réussis de plus en plus à décrocher pas
ce qui était en une machine qui roule
quand même bien y arrive quelque chose
de majeur je suis lol c'est toujours mon
téléphone mais j'ai réussi puisque
logiquement me permette un peu plus de
décrocher ce qui est le plus difficile
c'est tout sauter un peu tout piqué les
communautés locales web ce tu veux
vraiment jamais à moi qui aime subtil on
est un peu là dedans à voir comme un set
gorrite d'instagram à marcq
la jeunesse meetic homme qui sous la
pression des présents de
paul fort par présence et ça c'est des
fois les gens se battre
seppi j'aime mieux pas vous bougies
cités d'or alors j'espère aller bien que
j'enregistre y y et puis quand je vais à
vous dirigeants avant de nouvelles je
vais avoir quelque chose c'est boubet
que je veux me sentir une des zones et
des fois on ne laisse rien à vous mais
des fois c'est quand même pas pas un
monologue tout et pendant vingt-deux
story ça dépend des jours du fait que
j'essaie juste d'être vraiment en être
le pit pas faire alors je me dois de
mais des fois dans le jeu me dois t mais
des fois j'ai des gpo choix d'en avoir
quelques-uns c'est soit parce que par ce
qui est en même temps le mouton le
le beau problème avec avoir une équipe
qui s'agrandit comme ça c'est que veut
veut pas lier des gens qui dépend d'un
peu de dépendre la business pour vivre
la business dépend un peu de ton
implication c'est réseau social ce que
tu sais comme un peu 3 ça parce que la
business est liée à cet effet que le oui
c'est pas trop dessus et là oui c'est ma
franchise et al voilà la seconde où je
partage un nouveau tard par eco mais
aujourd'hui c'est fou merci d'avoir
partagé je sais que c'est un impact ça
cloche comme j'ai une responsabilité de
parme a brillé plateforme de vente ne
m'étais pas vendre alléger mais pas dans
gorge rien personne j'ai juste voici ce
qu'on a si ça vous plaît vous êtes les
bienvenus annonçant qu'il a dressée
diète aussi ce métier j'essaye vraiment
de le faire le plus honnêtement mais oui
il ya une certaine carrure exactement
c'est mais en même temps c'est une
obligation qu'il forme parce que je
contente de partager j'ai inventé un
tartare avec des cachous puis tout est
postée sur la toile sont exacts c'est
comme un petit essai de décrocher
mettant un devoir mais tu es contente de
le partie fixe tout un peu tout le temps
le présent enfin que j'essaye de faire
de mon mieux mais il ya des gens qui
m'aident aussi avec les plateformes
comme instagram perso si c'est moi mais
tu aimais tant olin sa g de juste
soucheyre maison qui les comptoirs ou
bien la page facebook on essaye de faire
de valoriser un peu de toutes qu'est ce
qu'on a pu mettre en lumière ce qu'on a
sur nos plateformes m'aimiez perso mais
qui est plus du tout le personnage que
tu as comme jean gignac qui comme ça
répondait pas au téléphone aujourd'hui à
sept îles
mais les gens m'écrivent à moi mais
c'est correct ça me fait plaisir de
répondre puis je vous demander à la
fille d état et aviez vous un problème
de téléphone tu est un exemple été mais
c'est ça mais je sais mais je suis mais
sushis
ça me dérange pas pierre avec les sushis
c'est vite arrivé par hasard quelques
maps et madame souche amende mais à la
télé ils ont écrit ça c'est un fait pas
madame je me fiche
du jeu politique et 4 po dijon pourquoi
la madame est venu de parler de sujets
qui fâchent aussi messi touche tous ces
élèves commencent à comprendre le
colosse il ya quatre ans limité mais
quand madame se met à genoux devant -
dans une crèmerie ascendante comme
tu me touches ibg pour le compte en
banque des sushis mettez pour mon garçon
je mal mais on essaie de tout mélanger
ça mais j'ai tout le temps content tu
fier pis je peux tu année puis 1 annoncé
comme c'est beau job le seui structal
décroche un peu mais pas souvent mais ça
ne dérange pas maintenant on sait qu'à
passer les fichiers
avi
moi ça me dérange pas
c'est mon c'est ma patiente et puis dans
dans ta vie qui est pop bain de ma vie
personnelle qui n'est pas professionnel
ce que met-on
est-ce que tu des est ce que tu es
capable de remettre en perspective
les événements difficiles mathon je suis
pas suivre m'exprime bien parce que
maintenant depuis tantôt en partie dont
on parle de son enfance on a parlé un
peu de ton enfance on a parlé de la vie
professionnelle vous souhaitez comme tu
es capable de bien adapter d'être aussi
capable d'appliquer ce cette
gestion de problèmes puis d'être capable
de rester en contact avec qu'est ce qui
est important risque réellement qu'à qui
t'arrive de quoi personnellement qui
plus difficile maintenant je vois ça
fait dix ans que je vais dire mais
exprime peut-être mal mais dans le sens
car il arrive un obstacle dans vie tout
dépendant ton bagage comment tu le vécu
qui ont hâte qu'elle personne tu es en a
qui vont réagir devant mêmes obstacles
comme si c'était la fin du monde qui
vont voir le tacle on part ça c'est rien
les gens mais je craignais puis elle
indiquera que je
suis pas moi c'est
les montagnes des gens pour moi c'est
comme un petit caillou c'est sa piste
c'est sûr que c'est des fois y'a
quelqu'un mettons une amie dois te
parler d'une situation de la grèce mais
simplement non parce que t on à tous ces
sorties on a tous notre personnalité
notre vie qu'une autre bagage qui était
je peux pas faire comme et voyons la
consigne est doté non je forte je suis
vraiment capable d'être à l'écouté de
comprendre que pour cette personne là
c'est vraiment difficile où tu as tout
bon fac oui je capable de vraiment de
faire la part des choses même avec
qu'est ce que j'ai vécu moi
personnellement par exemple j'essaie
d'acheter un humain gdg des sentiments
je veux pas de laisser tout le monde a
peur du rejet marie mai même si trois
goals aussi je ne réinvente pas roux
métier j'essaye à travers de ses hôtes
et autant que quand j'étais plus jeune
j'ai comme ça c'est pas bon pour moi tu
ou ben j'ai envie d'autre chose dans mes
relations j'essaie d'être bête c'est
peut-être pas sauter où je jouais autre
chose ou c'est pas une facteur ptg cgt
jugé ma personnalité aussi petit et
j'essaye de juste comme mieux délire
possible avec les situations comme tout
le monde mais si comme on fait ce qu'on
peut ouais oui mais c'est sûr que pas
grand chose de t'énerver mais oui il ya
quand même des choses qui m'énervent
parce qu'ils baissent les chauffe
lesquels j'ai pu contrôler aux semences
à
des contrôles sous le nom spahic youth
par germer en espérance st germain et
vouloir tout contrôler non mais non
métier j'aime bien des maux jr est le
type je parle poseurs de des ménages les
enfants de même que je parle juste et
j'aime savoir c'est
surtout gênant
mais j'aime savoir les choses en fait
j'aime dire les gens j'aime communiqué
vague si comme
voilà à présent quelque chose qui fait
l'autre les doigts
ça que j'exprime mes copains pour vrai
cette station là et autant avec mon
garçon 1
[Musique]
j'essaie de m'exprimer et demi que je
peux payer ça parle sur terre bien aimée
parce que je panique ou non plus pas
commenter je m'exprime bien et puis je
tiens était le gendre psg j'ai un
background affectés pichon était une
femme d'affaires une maman infectée j'ai
plein de
qualités je pense et beaucoup de défauts
aussi rassurez vous mais t'es où je peux
faire comme un témoin je peux bien adam
oates au pire mais ça avec mon nom mon
parcours puis tout ce que je vis qui me
permet d'être plus alerte à savoir dans
quoi je suis bien ou pas bien et puis
elle exprimé seul
hier quant à lui prend une bière puis on
parle t on écouter des podcasts que tu
as fait ton parler puis c'est ns est
amenée sur une discussion de ce que
c'est que d'être une personne forte ne
m'étonne météo on se dit que tu fit est
parfaitement cette description le t2
quelqu'un qui
que véhicule autant de difficultés puis
est parti avec autant de prises au bâton
qui aurait dit que sur papier on aurait
pu dire si je gâche pas de noms
exotiques et finalement tout ce que tu
as construit puis de le faire justement
sans jamais se plaindre sans jamais
s'apitoyer sur son sort vite et puis
c'est quand même de le faire des fois tu
comme tu dis on a on a chacun une
personnalité pour nous chacun mais mais
ça c'est impressionnant quand même tous
que devant ça à faire si ça ça démontre
une maudite grande force par exemple
merci dit gg magog si j'ai lu tellement
fêter ça marrant d'entendre type des
fois le
tu es candidats partout des fois je tati
qui plus est des fois je me donne pas le
droit d'être fatigué et épices comme si
j'ai toujours l'impression qu'il faut
que soit leur choix un pinscher dppi
sips opté c'est souvent ce ter qui comme
fo chez bull des fois j'ai même des fois
je me trouve pas être des belges
poserait divo métier chez jyske sommes
fatigués haute et juste comme y'en a
trop outils apprennent à faire qui est
oui je me rends compte que j'ai tout
bâti sopi mais en même temps j'essaie de
me garder justement a continué d'être la
même personne que je suis d'où je viens
du sopi enfin que c'est beaucoup de
pression mais en même temps c'est tout
valable tout on ait cessé comme je lui
rendais vraiment parce que je vous dis
pour vrai par la passion de faire goûter
marc forget a faxé sort hier c'est tout
le temps sommes encore le tpiy quand je
préfère les valeurs de toucher à la
maison parce que je veux qu'on les
affiches dessins d'employés je veux
rappeler au monde d'où je viens pas pour
faire un foyer d'où je viens mais
j'espère hey vous êtes en train de faire
les sushis d'une fille qui était resté
parce que le mon staff ça y ait du
roulement de ceux des fois le monde
c'est un petit savent même pas le cb
correct mais je commence je redoute le
rappeler parce que ça craint
appartenance puis ça ça crie quelque
chose de juste comme un jeu va donner un
petit quelque chose de plus ou moins
contents des petits outils peu importe
ça que j'essaye juste de toujours rester
glander sur mes valeurs la personne que
je suis petit métier je mange 0 l'a pas
que j'ai trop d'amis de longue date qui
me
je peux même pas envisagé devenir
quelqu'un d'autre mais tu attends je
voudrais pas parce que la mer
il ya aussi articule au collège des
radios télés où j'ai étudié mon
directeur d'école feu christian qui est
décédé il ya quelques années un moment
donné je me rappelle en temps une super
belle cohorte de filles très bonne
qu'ils allaient faire du show biz quel
est le faire
c'est vraiment le rayonner le milieu de
la télé ou de la radio qui je suis
rentré dans son bureau j'ai fermé la
porte derrière moi puisque christian
comment je vais faire moi pour me
démarquer que je n'avais pas touché à la
maison encore lost est vraiment tout
embryonnaire le bdi pour vrai restait
quand même c'est pas suffisant elles
sont toutes flamboyante des lots qui y
ont tout comme ati un background et des
familles avec des soucis près d'en faire
le beau métier puis y était contenants
et tutelle je reste moi mais
j'ai vraiment écouté son conseil parce
qu'on sentait que c'est le plus simple
le meilleur conseil de sous les pins à
vivre ça que j'ai juste partie de son
bureau que j'ai fait je veux faire ça
quand je me lève le matin j'ai pas le
masque d'un autre jeu
j'ai vendu mes recettes chuter je suis
honnête de dire oui à tout ce qui sort
les recettes par des fonds se croisent
au travers du chemin et elle et les
créateurs de recettes sa mamie
comme je disais on n'invente rien on
réinvente mais mais mais moi je le sais
que j'ai un vent de mes affaires moi je
sais que je suis moi même moi je sais
que je suis pas parti et que je fais mon
possible que je suis fier et merci à
tous les gens qui travaillent pour
rendre à la maison tout les jours
puis c'est quelqu'un qu'on ne peut être
totalement soi même ça demande quand
même un travail d'introspection de semer
un reste que c'est la chose la plus
facile et toi même le tube hey oui c'est
beau d'être qui quoi que ce soit et ça
peut donner un tel pitch au pis je lai
présente des fois c'est comme si c'était
trop facile de juste dire moi même je
vais faire ce qu'ils jouent au fait de
coin la chose dans laquelle je suis
naturellement bon c'est comme si quand
on entreprend quelque chose que ce soit
en entrepreneuriat que ce soit en or que
ce soit c'est comme si il fallait que ça
ça soit of fallait qu'on travaille fort
bien tandis que des fois ouais juste
parce que tu es bon pied juste rester
toi même si la chose tout comme pourrait
prendre travail et qui disait ça peut
pas être jetés dessus mais si
[Rires]
oui pour vrai ça m'arrive souvent s'est
ainsi dit vraiment mis le doigt sur
quelque chose que je vis depuis quelques
mois encore plus puisque mais faudrait
sûrement que je fasse plus tu payes
stephen non skorik aujourd'hui c'est
fait sur 7 mm soit faire le magazine lot
invente ici thello tu existes sait qu
orange comme énonce puis je me dis
toujours je passais bien trop le fun ce
big trouble fête mais pas facile mais
c'est tellement naturel jeu comme c'est
sûr qu'il faudrait que je reçois je
rentrais d'un tableau excel une fois par
an dall haute et voudrait sa machine et
ouvriers qui me fait chier parce que je
voudrais que ce soit chien
pixel plus de postes des journées des
semaines en exil doré perdu ton temps
parce que se pose est bonne mais qui est
quelqu'un qui est vraiment avant la
claque québec salvatore qui sont ceux
qui comme moi lâche t midi tableau bien
comment j'aime ce que je fais un petit
café pour me fait me dit ah blues comme
parfait c'est ce qui définit qui on est
il ya des artistes
il ya des y'a des gens cartésien et
déjanté c'est parfait parce qu'on
s'agencent ans continue mais c'est vrai
ça m'arrive souvent ces temps-ci encore
plus de faire comme c'est sûr que passer
mais tout à quelqu'un m'a dit ah ben oui
c'est correct et au pire on va te dire
ça on a besoin d'une recette ou quelque
chose passe moi c'est vraiment seul
c'est vraiment les menus lire certes les
créations le contenu puis d'être
présente le site toujours puis ça me
fout le plaisir mettez des fois c'est ça
mon travail c'est même un système facile
comme êtes sûrs et sûrement pas formulec
fauves rempli cette semaine me faire
tirer par deux
autres affaires aussi fille quand tu
réalises la seconde si tu réalises que
met-on quelqu'un qui connaît le jeu se
prend un exemple mettons de photoshop le
tit re est inquiétant graphismes le jeu
pourrait passer une journée complète
incident sur photoshop de faire un
dézingue ce sens du monde à aller
chercher sur google comment faire de la
forme ou banque paye un graphiste qu'il
a répondu cinq minutes ça va être la
meilleure affaire tout vu ta vie tu as
déjà parfait c'est ce jeu m'a fait ça me
coûtait vraiment moins cher que ma
journée complète ou ça coûte des sous
petits faits mais je comprends pour se
hisser sa exhorté mama dagnon travail de
lehman graphiste et les choses évoluent
les tarifs du plat des fois je sais
comment on prend juste magasin au revoir
mais c'est à peu près tout l'armement
faire les graphes et bon jusqu'à la
défense dite charte éthique à ses
poteaux métier était jusqu'à lors
finalement quand où et essaie de le
faire ou tu fais des soumissions tu fais
comme les autres le ils font à merveille
son bon pied oui c'est ça vaut ce que ça
vaut mais je le ferai jamais - france
versé chaque team hamadani c'était en
fait rouler l'économie de par les
capacités pièce les gens aiment
papillonne sûrement vanessa est dans son
bureau qui est qu au bout un mais les
couleurs puis comme a fait évoluer mon
bmc s'est cassé bob cemagref jusque
dessus du compte-rendu le parce qu'elle
ya des petites taches de tes réseaux ces
photos qui ces boutiques et magasins ce
travail d'équipé c'est même pas on se
parle pas c'est que c'est tellement
rigole système comme facile si on veut
que tout le monde met son grain de sel
littéralement pis la benne il devient ce
qu'il est parce que tout le monde commet
alors au premier de pastels huiles
pastels rien prémédité on est juste
comme tout passionné j'essaye vraiment
juste de m'entourer des gens qui aiment
ce qu'ils font pis moi ça paraît très
sûrs en plus c'est un tableau excel word
[Rires]
excel excellent il ya tellement d
enfants et oui non mais maintenant
quelqu'un qui serait quelqu'un qui est
capable qui maîtrisent excellent genre à
100%
sauf tout le temps du monde entier parce
que mettons moi j'ai déjà vu un tableau
le que tutu artistes comme si c'était
comme si
je changeais un chiffre
le tableau change au complet le taux de
change au comptant
toutes ces six mois mois sur excel c'est
comme excuse moi qui fais le calcul au
complet le sur une calculatrice externe
le faire juste le total à droite le
maire lâcherait pas me maquille
ou a fait toutes prêtes à marier au
dessus des petits des modèles quand tu
étais plus jeune
j'ai bien je dirais que le frein à mon
père andré avec qui je suis super
proches oui d'une certaine manière parce
que lui c'est un entrepreneur de québec
il ce qui est gros comptes publicitaires
l'instant publicis aux tiges en ashton
le gave la capitale mercedes benz québec
nanana des gros cons je t'aime je t'aime
brain impressionné est-ce que je dirais
que c'est un menteur non parce que j'ai
tellement débrouillarde quelqu'un comme
on forme une faute sur be été jeté comme
un peu puis lui à l'époque aussi savais
pas que j'allais bennwihr et fakty des
fois c'est un peu un tipi mon parent et
ehrhoff à cette époque lotim ont paraît
il laissait pas de place à des gens
nécessairement occupé de moi mais lui ne
pouvait pas mais il y avait là on petit
excès comme toute fin que j'étais un peu
tout seul ces facs il m'a beaucoup
inspiré puis mai mais si aujourd'hui kim
espère encore plus quand j'ai déjà
bartimée affaire parce que le lui est un
époque où l'huile par quasiment en pré
retraite mais il vient de sortir un gros
projet up mais quand même puis moi je
comme alors dans le milieu comme entre
1,2 kg on se rend compte qu'on ait le
même humain et urbain d enfer fax comme
de poti il me pas pris par la main ils
me posent mais il ya toujours été de bon
conseil était une fois de temps en temps
je fais un petit conseil faisait la
différence pour une année complète petit
marc pala manège avait été engagé comme
ge energy à québec l'a jeté comme magath
le jo je capotais lâcheté comment je
m'en branle les amis pas pratiquante
étudie la dda ces gens les anime à
penser comme il m'avait dit personne
d'un précieux secours à personnes
t'impressionne tout le monde est pareil
j'en fais juste des affaires petit
j'étais ok i'ma donner assez de conseil
c'est aussi vrai que c'est un bon
concept mais c'est pas gentil meilleur
que les autres
y a personne tu es pression et je te
peach up à cette impression merci la
raison à nos côtés à ok des fois j'en
prends jean laisse aussi parce que tu es
une vieille école une dégénération fait
plus aujourd'hui que tu malade s'est
fait le relais quand envoyé avec des
fois c'est moi maintenant qu'il
conseille qu'il ait fait que l'on n'ait
comme rendu à la même place mais dans
des générations différentes oula je
considère qu'ils aient vraiment quand
j'ai besoin je l'appelle puis content
parce que le ici tout ce que j'ai bâti
deux seuls skippeurs m'appelle c'est pas
comme quand tu démarres sais pas si ça
va marcher c'est comme je voulais tu
vaux rien la petite l'ôter tandis
qu'elle est comme j'ai fait mes enfants
enfin que même émeutes et une ré ci qui
était inspiration t moder j'en ai pas
vraiment c'est comment booster à ckoi
qui témoin tout mais ce petit jeu prend
un peu de plein d'affaires j'enregistre
mon cerveau me suis rendu compte que mon
subconscient était vraiment présent le
lac j'emmagasine j'emmagasine que mon
époux poppy c'est comme la vie c'est
comme
quand soi et petits tas magazine
d'information ce que la pub comme
n'importe quoi si moi je sais que c'est
seul chez moi le mot mon subconscient
pire qu'un magazine depuis que kamprad
connaissent mais bon mama fall of
question s'était tu es en fait khatera
canton histoire je sais pas si si si
c'est quelque chose que tout
que d'inutiles inconsciemment mais c'est
ce que demandent 30 ans ce qui vient
d'un milieu plus rough qui s'escrime
c'est possible de faire de quoi le type
qui doit être mon côté crise et des
conférences j'adore ce parce que c'est
nous c'est des réalités timos inégalités
puis tout tout si je pense quand on
vient envié de famille c'est
avec l'argent et
saviez des ficelles ou dans votre
critère qu'on avait difficile au pays je
me suis
frito la
première fois que j'étais en contact
avec tout est vraiment pas un contact
mais je pense que tu es là aussi c'est
alors une sortie scolaire nous on allait
le quelques instants le roi là on saura
qui était dans quartier saint-roch
telegraph
nous on est dans le programme stories et
quand tu rentrais dans l'école à gauche
tels pavillon sport-études et à droite
cet avion régulier puis par lyon
régulier s'était bâti les enfants les
enfants de saint roch puisse paraître
cette mode un peu partout qui venait
assez que le pour le préparer depuis
cédé programme thé que quelques fallait
que ce soit un peu plus sans moyens
parce que souvent ton sport il y avait
des tirs des voyages il y avait des
compétitions de soutien et demande
vraiment à une porte
s'est jamais su gel de leurs jupes les
deux mondes c'était sebha erreur le
monde du sport études qui s'est
uniquement des réguliers vers ceux de
tisser j'avais un goût dans mon ami que
sa blonde temps régulier piste -comme
c'est st estève terror ses 10 ans mais à
manu je me suis fait une sortie scolaire
puis on sent nettement la même place
puis dans même bus et vêtements de
régulier je me souviens on était assis
puis je pense la fille de l'ubs a
raconté à son ami ayalon prête encore
ses impôts de lapierre frappé ma mère
finale 1-1 ap le jeter comme c'est
tellement loin de la réalité puisque
j'avais pas encore conscience époque le
conseil que ça existe et est courant
piste propre roman bien plus courant que
je parle en ces mots tous mes amis tout
le monde dans mon milieu c'était comme
des familles est là pour ça que j'élève
mango dash larguent away ah ça pour ça
pour qu'ils soient conscients
ben oui croise une prostituée comme tu
croises une petite famille sans vos parc
qui je veux pas regarder
déjà mais je veux qu'ils partiront qui
côtoient les deux mondes basques avoue
te d'être perturbée mais quand même chez
les collines qui demande ce qui est le
cas
de l'ex permis de faire comme
prospection fait cinq ans oui vraiment
ouais puis c'est ce même site et moi
personnellement j'ai pas vu cultive même
dans une primaire on ajoute à l'école
saint-roch hippie au secondaire juste
avoir été plus insulter ou aux primaires
on est là en cours d'école il y avait
des seringues ne peut partir en cours
d'école pitt et des fois dans le petit
module d'enfants il ya un gars qui était
pasteur est l'hôte et puis qui venaient
faire une overdose mettons le tpiy facto
comme pas notre monde en même temps la
veine du sinaï qui fait qu'on voyait un
peu moins une autre réalité que si
j'avais juste à l'école dans sillery de
ma vie j'aurai mais oui pour les
domaines de vos parents vous est envoyé
justement assez rock parce qu'elle vous
auriez pu aller à
paris tous ses as raison mais était-ce
et ça vous a permis de voir s'il est ici
mais toi et ton l'eau par arrêté paul au
point de manon forme importe à qui
on aurait jamais eu ans et a conscience
du pitti aujourd'hui mais tout ça pour
dire qui est cette fille lena bus les
autistes ces gens là qui ont ce camp qui
tente andy doit quand même ces crimes je
peux vous et à répéter la même affaire
puis je peux m'en sortir et à forger un
témoignage est tellement contents du
tout mais je pense que oui j'avais
entamé mais se retourne sur la route
après la pandémie sommet de faire des
conférences la semidias et je suis loge
dans l'école secondaire dans le centre
pour jeunes qui sont lancés comme vient
parler après ou ou plus tard où on
vraiment un billet me demande à ton prof
qui me fasse un message comme ou juste
comme des années plus tard acheter leur
dans ta conférence à me vraiment motivé
j'ai décidé de faire telle affaire où
j'ai dénoncé mon par viel oui parce que
ma conférence touche à tout apport d'une
petite fille de limoilou et kinés de one
night tellement c'est mon père qu'elle
lui avait offert un enfant mais ensuite
tout genre la violence conjugale la
consommation de drogues apprécié le
déclic de règle pas ce que je veux dans
ma vie
de ce fait mon parcours que je finis par
te toucher août interpol et où tafer
prendre connaissance donc ce souhait
c'est que si tu avais pas est assez rock
matin je vois ton école à ses dirigeants
qu'à moi tu sané puis je parle bosch
pénale pas des filles de ghalem non plus
le fait que je rejoins encore j'ai
encore capable d'être assez jeune pour
rejoindre les jeunes puis assez
expérimenté pour aller toucher dans un
cabinet d'avocats faire une conférence
aussi pour j'espère au faux pas oublier
la réalité est encore s'il existe encore
sauter puis encore aujourd'hui le fac
team va quiz j'aime vraiment ça pour ce
parce que ça touche pistes et des fois
le monde me disait tu m il ya des gens
qui pensaient que j'avais comme qu'elle
m'a parlé mon histoire avant par thomas
business suite et je me rappelle mon nez
quelqu'un m'avait fait un commentaire
c'est à l'époque puisque tvq ne serait
peut-être pas autant utiliser ce
métier m'a donné mes parts et c'est
juste arrivé concours de circonstances
quelqu'un tendu mon histoire je pense et
jean isabelle maréchal était commettre
serait tu n'en parles et puis le petit
couple on avait fait un document par à
canal vie petit encore sur crève
aujourd'hui je fous le contente et je
pense qu'il est peut-être passé dans le
beurre finalement l'été les gens
l'écoutent encore aujourd'hui c'est à
date de 2016 piété c'est ça a un impact
y est et on travaille sur un projet de
film parce que il ya un message là
dedans kiki intemporel le train c'est
c'est juste comme un moment donné
c'était toi qui décides dit pee wee ça
peut-être peut-être plus ardue pour
certaines personnes pour plein de
raisons mais ça se peut juste ça c'est
juste ça se peut puis l'émission je
voudrais qu'on m'efface la vie vous
coûter 4 my god moi je
la maison à mai mais julie perreault ses
membres et puis c'est l'histoire de
trois familles qui vivent trois
situations difficiles différentes dans
trois apparitions vont piger s'est jetée
comme à saint louis en dentelle appart
dentelle à partie cette chute est chez
nous j'ai vécu comme j'écris et au
réalisateur
y à rien plus proche de la vérité que
seul le travail qui a été fait au niveau
de l'arrière la recherche et de saisie
comme irréprochable gens c'est tellement
vrai j'écrivais la en réel à monsieur
piccolo la réplique à l'outrance en ont
jeté comme merci le sait et j'en oublie
que bella la maman quant à chercher une
seringue propre qui qu'elle est une
fille travailleuse de rue le métier
j'aurai celle qui se promène avec les
trucs propre leur laisser le temps le
team mamère combien de fois j'ai eu peur
qu'on m'appelle qui était dans un corps
à corps avec une seringue salle qui
incrimine importe quoi dedans pour
prendre son fait que sahel où on est des
enfants dominent le jeu comme au en même
temps j'ai eu le regard de ce que je
t'ai pas là c'est comment va se chercher
des seringues rupture puis en même temps
je savais pas que ça me des images sur
comment marchait comme embrasser un
cherche des seringues
dans un krach a ajouté la ferté et aux
bailleurs comme un super être que je
veux pas vous le dire faut vraiment
voulu confier qu'il ya eu ce qu'on m'a
donné le
test chez nous s'était momentanément des
morceaux de bonheur parce que j'étais
content d'être avec ma mère elle avait
de l'argent est à l'âge d'un petit
poulet au dépanneur qui ont mangé ce
qu'on était contente d'être ensemble
mais cinq minutes après repartez ou la
dpj débarquer ou la violence commence et
où ces c'est juste comme c'est tellement
réaliste et mais en même temps c'est
tellement puma vie
des fois je suis comme j'ai vraiment de
vie métiers des fois on est comme vous
on a deux vies l'école secondaire mais
non mais moi c'est genre et le japon le
québec je suis vraiment
puisque pour sa tige et j'essaye
vraiment que mon garçon j'étais
tellement mon mieux mais en même temps
je peux pas paraître si tu deviens était
mon ami j'ai juste trouvé l'équilibré
pour qu'ils sachent que j'ai travaillé
fort dans la vie pour travailler mais en
même temps tu es chance aux pies qui
mérite ça parce que parce que tu es né
dans cet environnement là puis on veut
ton bien factice comme temps fort
possible c'est un garçon de 18 ans tohic
l'idée fruits commencent à voir les
déclics de que ma mère est connu c'est
comme différentes églises autre toit
caen ttc quelqu'un catastrophe
mettant des gardiens l'impact des
professeurs pas scandale et servent à
l'école puis j'avais des espadrilles en
plein hiver qui était troué j'avais des
bords en dessous mais j'avais mais
peut-être oui j'avais comme deux par
deux bosses sur mes bottes pour faire
une part de brooklyn qui est ma prof à
m'avait dit avec leur jolie édition où
tes bottes moi je mentais belle montée
pavée des petits mensonges blanc de gens
aux entreprises et où j'ai oublié chez
un ami et ses
oies mais j'avais comme mais j'avais
peur que j'avais juste pas envie d'en
parler genre je sais pas comme si
j'étais pas comme si je t'ai pas du tout
renfermé le 10 mai j'étais comme je
gardais des petites choses ses camarades
boeuf et enlève somme mais ça c'est le
cas leur faim là on va sécher sur la
glace quand le défaite mais bord il a
été comme si parce que la première
voudrait pas plus de temps savoir que
c'était très pop hip mal en point chez
nous parce que je n'étais je suis
heureuse d'ouvrir tout le temps fait que
ces gens là misère noire mais j'arrivais
poti et demain le texte est en fait j'ai
juste content d'être à l'école
tu entendes et avec mes amis j'étais
contente j'ai toujours eu la chance
d'être dans bones gagne c'est son si ça
peut faire un impact si je tends
gauloise moi vous était cardinal juan
monaco si j'arrivais le cardinal que
vous avez envie mais bref nakuru la
ccist est quand même beaucoup plus salée
boutique j'avais beaucoup d'amitié des
scooters plutôt depuis je me fondais
bien dans la masse et mes amis même ils
ont su après quand je me suis auto
déclara des pyjamas n'est pas juive est
sur un matelas coquille j'ai appelé la
dpj puis mes amis c'est comme s'ils
savaient même pas jean parquet ses
charmes de ce milieu oui ça que j'ai
fait ce que j'ai pu là mais même dans ce
sens webb à signaler pour toi c'est oui
il ya eu 10 calme à sanaa prat 3g était
mon troisième
famille d'accueil ouais un mois et sur
la rue des braves
mamans stars
ça apporte de
sa saisie ouais c'est autant qui était
je dis pas que vous veniez des maisons
comme ça mais testait com comment vos
amis d'école ou peu importe mais
moelleux j'avais jugeant mostra maison
de maman j'ai raté l'avion puis
oui parce que je t'ai pas à l'enfant
problème
écrit parce que je t'ai résiliente parce
qu'il ya sûrement les enfants qui en
avait plus besoin que moi puis à ce
moment là j'avoue j'étais quand même ses
poches mais là avec tout les systèmes
toute la bureaucratie que je comprendre
la dpj et les manies faut faire des
choix et des pétards ils pensent ils se
sont dit que j'allais m'en sortir bain
est clairement
plus tard tu es parti en appart pour
être
partie à sa guise au québec 15000 je
travaille chez mac do et j'ai lâché les
colosses j'ai mis ma particulier de et
j'ai pas plus dit ce dont j'avais
contenu
comme de coincer jessie j
mais comme de quoi c'est vraiment d être
les parcours peuvent bomber
ou boucher l'expression le tous les
parcours même à rome mais
soutient maintenant ni qui on est et on
commençait avec sa tante il en est qui
on est à moment donné puis après cette
stratégie sipi tau fondamentalement
teyton détresse t'es pas bien tu vas t
on ici on est oui on met moins vraiment
certaine c'est extraordinaire tout le
temps ton histoire et écrasent leurs
pieds ou est ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
encore si fulgurant
merci par éteindre ex comme j'ai été un
peu comme ma job market
jusque gérard berge attend mieux pis ça
chez que tu te
projette pas dans le futur mais mettons
le ta vie dans dix assurent sans makoun
hayat
mêlant pauvres
et j'ai un peu un rêve bizarre la maison
comme ça sur casillas c'est juste en
réalité à la maison en plus jeune des
petites franchises depuis un moment
donné je suis que tes joies pouvoir
comme me retirer dentiste 12 12 heures
mais pas me retirer complètement parce
que je sais que c'est chez moi cg si je
vois jamais mais
j'aimerais ça qu'on sort des vannes
j'aime vraiment faire la route moi j'ai
jamais parti en vertu et disposerait la
baie saint paul on pensait fac je crois
que c'est vraiment beau le métier j'aime
ce la route deuxième l'espèce de m
j'aime conduire si je dis jamais les
autos j'aime vraiment conduire enfin que
j'essaie pas attendre et que je me dis
pas très conduit les femmes touchent à
la mer aux beaux jours de retraite c'est
camionneuse
a été juste voir j'aime voyager je
voyage des jo mais je dois je sais pas
on dirait que j'aimerais faire des
déchets pas que mango gens qui peuvent
pas car je sais pour 15 afin qu'ils
voient ça comme ça mais si je sais pas
ce que j'aimerais c'est que j'aimerais
ça conduit rendrait que je me vois genre
partir puis mais toujours inclure pas ce
que c'est on a la chance aujourd'hui
fakty et puis mais où travaillent pour
cissé vrais gens pour rien je me dis je
pourrais me promener avec des 26 à la
maison j'ai travaillé pour
ça
qu'il ya un monsieur que je connaisse la
retraite qui a vendu démissionne toute
sa vie puis là c'est petit ça en face
pour installer des piscines qui est le
plus plébiscité qui contre et je pense
qu'on est toujours c'est moi ma passion
va jamais partir puis j'essaie de tout à
me disent que j'aime c'est plus j'aime
conduire je me dis [ __ ] je vois
conduit là où je pourrai t je ne sais
pas le fait que je veux juste comme
continue parce que j'aime bien vu que je
me conduis je me disais quand je vais
avoir bild et quelque chose le juste
continue de faire ce que j'aime le team
s'est longuement fait pas de cas ça
inquiète allait super bien fait qu'on
souhaite que faire si depuis des mois
merci d'avoir écouté ce podcast jusqu'à
la fin de ce père que vous avez apprécié
la conversation ça prouve que vous êtes
de réelles fans de conversation et du
sans-fil pas de casser on vous remercie
vraiment beaucoup si vous voulez avoir
plus de contenus plus de conversations
sur pétillante que ça se passe il ya sur
p tu es un non seulement on met tous les
podcasts en ligne au moment où est ce
qu'on les tombes donc on a beaucoup de
semaine d'avant sur le pétrole mais on
fait aussi des encore moins de filtres
qui sont exclusifs aux membres pqls que
on parle d'homme n'est que l'émoi de la
conversation qu'ont bien d'avoir ce
qu'on met un peu plus en profondeur dans
certains sujets qu'on voulait aborder ou
qu'on a abordé pendant le podcast donc
allez sur une page de turenne les le
lien vers savoir dans la description du
podcast qui remercie encore une fois de
nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fin